Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Citizens, the National Convention trusting in your courage hereby accepts your oaths of loyalty. The liberty of your homeland will be the reward for your efforts. And while you defend your liberty with the force of your arms, the National Convention will defend it by the force of the laws. The monarchy is hereby abolished. So that Dominic was yet another person shouting loudly, one of many in our ongoing history
感谢收听《The Rest is History》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。公民们，国民公会信任你们的勇气，在此接受你们的忠诚誓言。保卫祖国的自由将是对你们努力的奖赏。在你们用武力捍卫自由的同时，国民公会也将用法纪来捍卫它。特此废除君主制。所以多米尼克又是那个大喊大叫的人，他是我们正在进行的这段历史中的众多声音之一
of the French Revolution. And it was specifically Jérôme Pétion, who was president of the National Convention on the 21st of September, 1792. And obviously the abolition of the French monarchy after centuries and centuries and centuries. This is a seismic moment, isn't it? In the history of France, but also of Europe? It's a massive moment, Tom, and I think the only voice that really is appropriate to the moment is the one you did there. I mean, because I detected more than a hint of our old friend, Jeremy Corbyn.
法国大革命的历史。他是热罗姆·佩蒂翁，1792年9月21日国民公会的主席。显然，在经历了长年累月、数个世纪之后，法国君主制被废除了。这是一个震撼性的时刻，不是吗？不仅在法国历史上，在欧洲历史上也是如此？这是一个巨大的时刻，汤姆，我认为真正适合这个时刻的声音只有你刚才那种。我的意思是，因为我在其中听出了我们的老朋友杰里米·科尔宾的一丝风范。
Is that right? Yes, because I think that Jeremy Corbyn, he would definitely be on the side of abolishing the monarchy had he been in the French Revolution. I think he probably regrets that he wasn't part of the French Revolution. Yes, I imagine that is. Well, he's always got cable streets, hasn't he? So yes, this is a massive moment in French and European history, isn't it? Because the French monarchy, I guess, one of the oldest in Europe.
是这样吗？是的，因为我认为如果杰里米·科尔宾经历过法国大革命，他肯定会站在废除君主制这一边。我想他可能很遗憾自己没有参与法国大革命。是的，我想是的。好吧，他一直都很有卡布尔街（Cable Street）的风范，不是吗？所以是的，这是法国和欧洲历史上一个巨大的时刻，不是吗？因为法国君主制，我想，是欧洲最古老的君主制之一。
If you take it back to Clovis, who we talked about just before Christmas, didn't we? So yeah, I mean, that's the end of that story. Yes, it is. So it sends shockwaves across Europe. We will be talking about what it means. And of course we will be talking about what it means for Louis XVI. And we'll get to his story in our final episode. Nothing good.
如果你把它追溯到我们在圣诞节前不久谈到的克洛维，对吧？所以是的，这就是那个故事的结局。是的，确实如此。因此，它在整个欧洲引起了震撼。我们将讨论这意味着什么。当然，我们也会讨论这对路易十六意味着什么。我们将在最后一集讲到他的故事。没有什么好事。
Nothing good. But before we get to the moment when they actually do abolish the monarchy, we should set the scene a little bit, Tom. We love setting the scene on this podcast. Well we did in the previous episode We set it in the context of the role of women didn't we but shall we we go back to the lads? What are the lads up to? Let's set it in the context of Prussians and cannons. Oh Prussians. So The situation in Paris people will remember from the last episode but one Paris is preparing for an attack
没有什么好事。但在我们讲到他们真正废除君主制的那一刻之前，汤姆，我们应该先铺垫一下背景。我们很喜欢在这个播客里铺垫背景。好吧，我们在上一集里做过了，我们把它放在女性角色的背景下，对吧？不过，我们要不要回到小伙子们身边？小伙子们在干什么？让我们把它放在普鲁士人和大炮的背景下。哦，普鲁士人。所以，巴黎的局势，大家从倒数第二集里还记得，巴黎正在准备迎接进攻。
There are church bells ringing There are cannons on the river Seine that are calling people to prepare for war. The streets are packed with volunteers who are streaming towards the gates of the city to the front. People are pulling down the grills of churches. They're digging up their coffins to use as lead for musket shots. There are everyday contingents of troops marching through the National Assembly, singing patriotic songs and shouting slogans and stuff. So it's all excitement. Jeremy Corbyn would actually have loved it. But it's not a Sandbrook vibe, is it?
教堂的钟声在响，塞纳河上的大炮在呼吁人们准备战争。街上挤满了志愿者，他们正涌向城市大门，前往前线。人们在拆除教堂的铁栅栏。他们挖出棺材，用来做火枪弹的铅。一队队日常的军队正行进通过国民议会，唱着爱国歌曲，喊着口号之类的。所以一切都充满了激情。杰里米·科尔宾其实会很喜欢这个。但这可不是桑德布鲁克（Sandbrook）的风格，对吧？
Not really a Sandbrook vibe, I would say. Although slightly more Sandbrookian, somewhere out there. Yes, the doer defenders of reaction. Yes, the woods and valleys to the east are the Prussians. The Duke of Brunswick, the real hero of this story. So on the 20th of September, so that's the day before the reading that you began with, the new national convention meets for the first time. Now some listeners, if they've made it all the way through the series, series Maybe like I've lost track of all the different assemblies and whatnot. So if you remember
我想，这确实不太像是桑德布鲁克会有的风格。尽管在某个地方，带有一点桑德布鲁克的色彩。是的，反动派的顽固捍卫者。是的，东边的树林和山谷里是普鲁士人。不伦瑞克公爵，这个故事真正的英雄。所以在9月20日，也就是你开始朗读的那天前一天，新的国民公会迎来了第一次会议。现在，有些听众如果一集不落地听完了整个系列，可能会觉得……可能会觉得像我一样，把各种不同的议会之类的东西都搞混了。所以如果你还记得
There had been the stormy the Tuileries In August and since then France has been a political limbo and they have basically summoned yet another Semi constituent assembly this one has unlimited powers to remake the nation and it is by far the most democratic yet. So all men over the age of 21, except for servants can vote. Because we talked about that last time and you said that you weren't in favour of it. Yeah, I don't agree with this at all. I mean, if I've I'm with the Jika Brunswick on this, I think it's a dangerous, a dangerous
八月份杜伊勒里宫曾发生过暴动，自那以后，法国一直处于政治真空状态，他们基本上又召集了另一个准制宪议会，这个议会有着重塑国家的无限权力，而且它是迄今为止民主化程度最高的一个。因此，除仆人外，所有21岁以上的男性都可以投票。因为我们上次谈过这个，而你说过你并不赞成。是的，我一点也不赞同。我的意思是，我跟不伦瑞克公爵站在一边，我认为这是一个危险的、危险的
innovation. Failed experiment. Yes, exactly. So it's very complicated electoral system, a series of electors and kind of almost like an electoral college and then they choose the 749 deputies. But as you said, Tom, their turnout is really poor. So in some places it might be a fifth, but generally it's probably one in 10. And the reason for that, I think, is there's a war on. So it's, you know, people have got other things in their mind, but it's also harvest time. So in the countryside, people have definitely got other priorities. And they actually, a lot of people are now completely confused. They're probably even more confused than listeners to the podcast.
失败的实验。是的，完全正确。所以这是一个非常复杂的选举制度，有一系列的选举人，有点像选举团，然后他们选出749名代表。但正如你所说，汤姆，他们的投票率真的很低。所以在某些地方可能是五分之一，但总体而言可能十分之一。我认为原因在于，当时正在打仗。所以，你知道的，人们脑子里还有别的事情，但这也是收获的季节。所以在乡村，人们绝对有其他的优先事项。而且实际上，现在很多人彻底糊涂了。他们可能比这个播客的听众还要糊涂。
They have no idea what's going on. They don't know who anybody is. Yeah, well, yes, exactly. And also on top of that, there's quite a lot of intimidation, isn't there? There is. That's another aspect to it. Of course. Remember, we did that episode about mad elections in Britain, where, you know, people being carried on chairs and whatnot, and like, lots of throwing of cats. Well, similarly, similarly in France for the National Convention, the voting is public and it is oral. You vote, you know, you say who you want to vote for. So if you want to vote in favor of a royalist party, you're basically standing up and saying, I am a reactionary traitor to La Patrie in front of all your fellow villagers.
他们根本不知道发生了什么。他们不知道任何人是谁。好吧，是的，完全正确。除此之外，还有相当多的恐吓，不是吗？确实如此。这也是其中的另一个方面。当然。还记得吗，我们做过那一集关于英国疯狂选举的节目，你知道的，人们被抬在椅子上游行什么的，还有像扔猫之类的。好吧，同样地，在法国国民公会的选举中，投票是公开的，而且是口头的。你投票，你知道的，你说出你想投给谁。所以如果你想投票支持保皇党，你基本上就是当着所有同村村民的面站起来说：“我是一个背叛祖国的反动叛徒。”
Who are like holding clubs and stuff and sort of leering at you in a sinister way. So clearly a lot of people just don't want to turn out. So in Paris, the voting has coincided with the September massacres. That's what we began this little kind of mini series with. So the atmosphere is very grim because as people are voting, there is the kind of... They're stepping over corpses. Right. The dull sound of hacking coming from inside the walls of the converted
他们手里拿着棍棒之类的东西，用一种阴险的眼神斜眼看着你。所以很显然，很多人根本不想去投票。因此在巴黎，投票与九月大屠杀同时发生。这就是我们这个迷你系列的开端。所以气氛非常阴森，因为人们在投票时，正踩着……他们正跨过尸体。没错，从隔壁改建的修道院高墙内传来了沉闷的砍杀声。
convent just down the road. So what is worse? The second round of voting is held at the Jacobin club. So if you are a royalist or reactionary, this is not the ideal place to go and, um, to sort of pin your colors to the mast. And that round of voting, the Jacquemint Club, they've got a lot of kind of electors, but they start by agreeing that they'll purge all electors who are foillon, who are moderates
那么，什么更糟？第二轮投票在雅各宾俱乐部举行。所以如果你是一个保皇党或反动派，这绝对不是一个去表态、去亮明立场的好地方。在雅各宾俱乐部的这一轮投票中，他们有很多种类的选举人，但他们首先达成一致，要清洗所有属于斐扬派（Feuillant）、温和派的选举人。
or who are royalists. So 200 electors are kicked out, there's 800 left, and they vote for 24 deputies. And of those deputies, a lot of those are very big revolutionary names. So the top of the list, number one, their top choice for Paris is Rob Speer. And then you've got people like Danton, Desmoulins, Sontaire, the butcher, the sonculots who'd led the attack on the Tuileries. Marat for the first time, this firebrand radical journalist, he is going to have a seat in
或是保皇党的选举人。因此，200名选举人被踢出局，还剩800人，他们投票选出了24名代表。在这些代表中，有许多是非常响亮的革命名字。所以榜单之首，第一名，他们对巴黎的首选是罗伯斯庇尔。然后你还有像丹东、德穆兰、屠夫桑泰尔（发动对杜伊勒里宫进攻的无套裤汉领袖）。马拉第一次作为这个激进火爆的记者，他将在国民公会中拥有一个席位。
the convention. So there will be a place for the most extreme, the most violent, the most paranoid revolutionary sentiments. And there's a place isn't there for the worst man in the entire history of the French revolution. The erstwhile Duke of Orléans, the cousin of Louis XVI, Philippe Egalité. I mean, we've talked about this before. This is Prince Harry calling himself Harry diversity or something, renaming himself. And actually-
因此，这里将会有最极端、最暴力、最多疑的革命情绪的一席之地。这里难道没有法国大革命整个历史中最糟糕之人的位子吗？路易十六的堂弟、前奥尔良公爵——菲利普·平等（Philippe Égalité）。我的意思是，我们以前讨论过这个。这就好比哈里王子自称为“多元哈里”之类的，给自己改了名字。实际上——
No, Harry equity. Harry equity, yeah. While living in his palace. Yeah, that's what he'd call himself. Yeah, Harry equity. Anyway, so everybody goes to the Tuileries on the 20th of September to register and they do so in an atmosphere of apocalyptic dread because they know that 140 miles away the Prussians are there and that their troops, their Francis troops have basically caught up with the Prussians.
不，是“公平哈里”。公平哈里，对。一边住在他的宫殿里。对，他会这么叫自己。对，公平哈里。不管怎样，9月20日，每个人都去杜伊勒里宫进行登记，他们是在一种末日般恐惧的气氛中进行的，因为他们知道140英里外普鲁士人就在那里，他们的军队，法兰西军队基本上已经追上了普鲁士人。
And the Duke of Brunswick, just to remind people, has said that he is going to inflict a biblical fate on Paris. He has, yeah. A vengeance which will be forever remembered, or words to that effect. So yes, now of these guys who've turned up to register, about half of them are lawyers. So if you're, we've got a lot of lawyers who are members of Arrested History Club. So they will love all this.
而不伦瑞克公爵，提醒一下大家，曾说过他要对巴黎降下圣经般的命运。他确实说过。一场会被永远铭记的复仇，或者是类似意思的话。所以是的，现在这些来登记的人当中，大约有一半是律师。所以如果……我们有很多律师是“The Rest is History”俱乐部的会员。所以他们一定会喜欢这一切。
They will see this is a very good sign. There's also loads of doctors, loads of civil servants, loads of actors, journalists. They're very young by and large, about half of them are under 40, about a quarter of them are under 35. The younger they are, the more committed and more militant they are by and large. So a lot of them have got experience in kind of local governments and stuff, but these aren't incredibly seasoned people. They are excited and excitable, I these aren't incredibly seasoned people. They are excited and
他们会认为这是一个非常好的迹象。这里还有大量的医生、大量的公务员、大量的演员、记者。总的来说他们非常年轻，大约有一半人在40岁以下，大约四分之一的人在35岁以下。总的来说，他们越年轻，就越坚定、越好战。所以他们很多人都有地方政府之类的工作经验，但这并不是指这些人经验异常丰富。他们兴奋而且易冲动，我认为这些人的经验并非格外老到。他们既兴奋又
excitable. I think it's fair to say. Kind of quite a student union vibe. Definitely. This is the birth of the student union really, isn't it? I think it probably is. Yeah. Motions, all that kind of stuff. Yeah, they love it. And they're there all night, you know, just endlessly arguing and showing off in that student union. And drinking. Exactly. Next day, 21st of September, they assemble at the riding school, the Manège for their first proper session. And that, this is the bit that you started with Jérôme Pétion, because they've come straight to the central question. Let's reboot France and it must be a republic.
易冲动。我觉得这样说很公平。有点学生会的气氛。绝对是。这简直就是学生会的诞生，不是吗？我想大概是的。是的。动议，诸如此类的事。是的，他们喜欢这样。他们整晚都在那里，你知道的，在那个学生里没完没了地争论和炫耀。还喝酒。完全如此。第二天，9月21日，他们在骑术学校（Manège）集合，举行他们的第一次正式会议。然后，这就是你以热罗姆·佩蒂翁开头的那部分，因为他们直接切入了核心问题。让我们重启法国，它必须是一个共和国。
There's an actor, of course, called Colo de Bois. He ends up on the committee of public safety later on. He says, let's just abolish the monarchy right away. No referendums and all that stuff. Let's just go for it. Some of the deputies say, really? No, no, you wouldn't let the people have a say on this? Such a massive question. And then the Bishop of Blois. So this is an interesting thing because again, it complicates the slightly sort of stereotypical sense of the French Revolution because it's a Bishop Henri Grégoire who says, Kings are in the moral world, what monsters are in the physical
当然，有一个叫科洛·代布瓦（Collot d'Herbois）的演员。他后来加入了救国委员会。他说，让我们马上废除君主制吧。不要什么全民公决之类的东西。直接干吧。有些代表说，真的吗？不，不，你们怎么能不让人民对此发表意见呢？这么大的问题。然后是布卢瓦主教。所以这是一件有趣的事情，因为这再次让法国大革命那略显刻板的单一印象变得复杂起来，因为正是主教亨利·格雷戈尔（Henri Grégoire）说道：“国王在道德世界中，正如怪物在物理世界中一样，他们的宫殿是罪恶的作坊和暴君的巢穴。”换句话说，不要全民公决。我们直接除掉他们。然后，他们投票了。当然，正如这种场景中经常发生的那样，非常具有学生会作风，一旦人们摸清了风向，大家就一拥而上了。
world, their courts are the workshops of crime and the layers of tyrants. In other words, no referendum. Let's just get rid. And they, they vote. And then of course, as so often happens in these kinds of scenarios, very student union, once people work out which way the wind is blowing, they all pile in. Yeah, they all pile in. So they make the vote unanimous. They all start shouting Vive la Nation. They're all terribly excited. The world has started
是的，大家都一拥而上。所以他们一致投票通过。大家开始高呼“法兰西万岁”（Vive la Nation）。他们都兴奋得无以复加。世界重新开始了。
again. But Dominic, just to pick up one thing that is intriguing and it's a kind of absence is that there isn't a kind of formal proclamation of the Republic. There's no official decree kind of installing it. And I just mentioned that because in the next episode, when we come to the trial of the king, I think that is significant. And I think that that is something that frames what will happen with the trial and the execution of the King, because although it is a new beginning, although they've had the vote, it's kind of, they know what they're getting rid of, but they don't yet know what they're establishing.
但是多米尼克，顺便说一句，有一件耐人寻味的事情，那就是某种缺失，即并没有对共和国进行某种形式的正式宣告。没有官方法令来确立它。我之所以提到这一点，是因为在下一集中，当我们谈到对国王的审判时，我认为这具有重要意义。而且我认为这正是塑造国王审判和处决走向的关键背景，因为尽管这是一个新的开始，尽管他们已经进行了投票，但某种程度上，他们知道自己在摆脱什么，却还不知道自己正在建立什么。
Yeah. I think that's a very fair point actually, that there is a sense of, there's a sense of historical time beginning again, but they don't really know what they all want because I suppose Tom, they don't want the same thing as we shall see in this episode. So if you enjoy political factionalism, this is definitely the rest is history episode for you. Anyway, one of the interesting things about the French Revolution that we've talked about so much is the way it faces two ways.
是的。我认为这确实是一个非常公允的观点，那就是有一种历史时间重新开始的感觉，但他们其实并不知道大家到底想要什么，因为我想汤姆，正如我们将在这一集里看到的那样，他们并不想要同一样东西。所以如果你喜欢政治派系斗争，这绝对是属于你的那集《The Rest is History》。无论如何，关于法国大革命，我们讨论过很多次的一个有趣之处在于它面对着两个方向。
On the one hand, they're looking back to the Roman Republic, as you have described so many times. And on the other hand, they're genuinely thinking this is not just a new chapter, but it's basically a new volume in world history. So they say from September the 20th, all state documents must bear the date year one of the French Republic. So this is where we get the beginning of the sort of French revolutionary calendar, the numbering system, year one, year two, and so on and so forth. But of course, whether they actually get beyond year one is not in their hands. It depends on events out on the battlefield. So let us now, let us leave Paris, turn the camera and turn the camera.
一方面，正如你无数次描述的那样，他们在回溯罗马共和国；而另一方面，他们真心认为这不仅是一个新章节，而且基本上是世界历史上的一个新卷宗。因此他们宣布，从9月20日起，所有国家文件都必须标上“法兰西共和国元年”的日期。这就是我们所知道的法国革命历法、编号系统（元年、二年等等）的开端。当然，他们能否跨过元年并不由他们自己决定，这取决于战场上的局势。所以现在让我们离开巴黎，转换镜头，转换镜头。
Exactly. You know how my mind works. So remember where we got to the Prussians have been marching all the way West from the border. They've got to the Argonne forest. That's 130 or so miles away from Paris. It's pouring with rain. Very Agincourt scenes, Tom.
没错。你知道我的思维方式。所以记住我们讲到了哪里，普鲁士人一直在从边境一路向西挺进。他们已经到达了阿贡森林。距离巴黎大约130英里左右。大雨倾盆。非常有阿金库尔战役的景象，汤姆。
There's only one man who can stop them. And that man is a guy called General Charles-Francois Dumouriez. So listeners may remember he's this kind of grizzled ex secret agent, ex seven years war veteran who was foreign minister under the Girondins. He got France into this mess in the first place. And basically he's in charge of the Eastern front. He really wanted to, he loves fighting Belgians. He loves attacking Belgium. That's his dream. He really wanted to, he loves fighting Belgians. He loves attacking
只有一个男人能阻止他们，那个男人就是查尔斯-弗朗索瓦·迪穆里埃（Charles-Francois Dumouriez）将军。听众们可能还记得，他是个饱经沧桑的前秘密特工、前七年战争老兵，曾在吉伦特派手下担任外相。他一开始就把法国拉进了这个烂摊子里。基本上，他负责东线。他真的很想……他热爱跟比利时人打仗。他喜欢进攻比利时。那是他的梦想。他真的很想……他热爱跟比利时人打仗。他喜欢进攻
Belgium. That's his dream. He wants to liberate Belgium. But the convention has basically said, forget about Belgium. There's a load of Prussians advancing on Paris. Get to the Valley of the Marne and stop them. There's a lot of maneuvering and faffing around. Do you want to go into detail about that? I do you know what I could I could but I won't because I don't want to try the patience of our less military minded listeners exactly. How many divisions are there on both sides? Loads. So to cut a very long story short the two armies end up faffing around and maneuvering
比利时。那是他的梦想。他想解放比利时。但国民公会基本上对他说：“别管比利时了。有一大群普鲁士人正在向巴黎推进。去马恩河谷阻止他们。”这里有大量的调兵遣将和瞎忙活。你想详细讲讲这个吗？你知道吗，汤姆，我其实可以，但我不会，因为我不想考验我们那些对军事不太感兴趣的听众的耐心。完全正确。双方有多少个师？很多。所以长话短说，两支军队到最后都在瞎忙活、调兵遣将，
and basically they end up on the wrong side of each other. So the Prussians are nearest Paris and Jemurais is behind them with his back against the Argonne forest. Now the Jacob Brunswick could just ignore Jemurais and could just dash on, could need to Paris. He could, but he doesn't want to do that because he, that would mean do you, Murray could cut his supply lines, basically cut him off from the German States and his men are very muddy and it's pouring rain. They're knackered.
基本上他们跑到了对方的错误一侧。所以普鲁士人离巴黎最近，而迪穆里埃则在他们身后，背靠着阿贡森林。现在，不伦瑞克公爵本可以无视迪穆里埃，直接冲过去，直奔巴黎。他本可以这样做，但他不想这么做，因为那意味着迪穆里埃可以切断他的补给线，基本上把他同德意志各邦隔离开来，而且他的士兵浑身是泥，大雨倾盆。他们筋疲力尽。
The shorter food, they're ravaged by illness. It feels a bit, a bit Henry the fifth before Ashen core. And he says, right, what we'll do is we'll stop here. We'll turn, we'll finish off to Murray and then we can secure our supply lines and then we can go on to Paris. To me, Ray is massively outnumbered, but he had very good news for him. So on the 19th, the day before the national convention, they meet to register. He is reinforced by a second French army under general Kellerman, who has a German name.
食物短缺，饱受疾病蹂躏。这感觉有点像阿金库尔战役前的亨利五世。他说：“好吧，我们要做的是，留在这里。我们转身，消灭迪穆里埃，然后我们就能确保补给线安全，接着再向巴黎进发。”迪穆里埃在人数上处于绝对劣势，但他有一个非常好的消息。所以在19日，也就是国民公会开会登记的前一天，他得到了第二支法兰西军队的增援，这支军队由凯勒曼（Kellerman）将军率领，他有一个德国名字。
He has a German name. Very confusing. Yeah, that Very confusing. Yeah, that is confusing. So these troops that they have, by the way, everybody always thinks this is a great victory for kind of people in red bonnets, shouting about the revolution. But it's not, is it? They're all basically Royalist officers and seasoned veterans.
他有一个德国名字。非常令人困惑。是的，那——非常令人困惑。是的，这很令人困惑。顺便说一句，他们拥有的这些军队，每个人都总是认为这是戴着红色无边帽、高喊革命口号的人民的一场伟大胜利。但事实并非如此，对吧？他们基本上都是保皇派军官和经验丰富的老兵。
And so they are, they are, these are like regular troops. And they also have, um, brilliant kind of new cannon they do indeed they have a very exciting new canon we love military technology on this podcast they have new lightweight cannons that were specially designed after the french had shamed themselves in the seven years war gets britain exactly they'd lost to everybody hadn't they it'd been a kind of world war they've been fighting the prussians or whatever so the 20th, so this is the day that the national convention were registering. On the 20th, it's a misty foggy morning, Kellerman outside this windmill outside the village of Valmy, he lines up his men on this ridge and he's got his lovely lightweight cannons
所以他们是，这些就像是正规部队。而且他们还有，嗯……非常出色的新型大炮。他们确实有，他们有一种令人兴奋的新大炮。我们在这个播客里很喜欢军事科技。他们拥有在法国人在七年战争中让自己蒙羞后专门设计的新型轻型大炮，被英国人给——完全正确。他们输给了所有人，不是吗？那是一场世界大战，他们跟普鲁士人打过仗之类的。所以到了20日，也就是国民公会正在登记的那天。20日那天，是一个大雾弥漫的早晨，凯勒曼在瓦尔米（Valmy）村外的这座风车旁，把他的士兵排成一排，站在山脊上，他带着他那些非常渴望炫耀的心爱轻型大炮。
that he's very keen to show off. The Prussians start firing with their cannons. Kellerman fires back with his, there's hundreds of guns blazing away through the fog. Now, do you know who was fighting for the Prussians? I do. It was Goethe, the great German writer, the greatest German writer. Germanist top writer Goethe. He was fighting with his patron who was Grand Duke Karl Augustus Saxe Weimar.
普鲁士人开始用他们的大炮开火。凯勒曼用他的大炮回击，数百门大炮在浓雾中轰鸣。现在，你知道谁在为普鲁士人作战吗？我知道。那是歌德，伟大的德国作家，最伟大的德国作家。日耳曼顶级作家歌德。他是同他的赞助人、萨克森-魏玛的大公卡尔·奥古斯都一起作战的。
Was he actually fighting? I always wondered about that because I thought he just kind of you know he'd gone in the train and was writing a poem. Well this is the thing I think there's no evidence I think of him actually shooting anybody. I can't imagine him in a uniform. That seems very odd. He must have been wearing uniform though because as we will discover he's exchanging banter with the lads of the battalion and stuff. Goethe said, I mean, you expect great prose from a great writer, don't you? Do you know what he said?
他真的在打仗吗？我一直对这一点很好奇，因为我以为他只是，你知道的，坐着火车去了，然后一直在写诗。这就是问题所在，我认为没有证据表明他真的开枪打过任何人。我无法想象他穿制服的样子。那看起来太奇怪了。但他当时一定穿了制服，因为正如我们将要发现的那样，他正在与营里的小伙子们开玩笑、聊天。歌德曾说过——我的意思是，你对一位伟大的作家会抱有伟大散文的期待，对吧？你知道他是怎么说的吗？
The earth literally trembled. It was a clash of titans. France, a land of contrasts. Anyway, the earth is literally trembling. Goethe can't believe it. What scenes. This goes on for hours and hours and hours and then the Prussians eventually say, okay enough, we've definitely softened the French up now.
大地真的在颤抖。这是一场巨人之战。法国，一个充满对比的土地。不管怎样，大地真的在颤抖。歌德简直不敢相信。真是惊心动魄的场面。这种情况持续了整整好几个小时，然后普鲁士人终于说：“好了，够了，我们绝对已经把法国人打得有所松动了。”
And Brunswick sends his infantry advancing in these kind of long lines, blue uniforms, they're advancing up the hill. They're convinced that the French are about to collapse. But no, General Kellerman takes off his hat with its trickler cockade and he lifts it up on his sword and he shouts, Vive la Nation! And then the French will start singing the Saira, one of their revolutionary songs. But interestingly, not the Marseillaise, which apparently there's no
不伦瑞克派遣他的步兵以这种长长的队列向前推进，身穿蓝色制服，他们正艰难地爬上山坡。他们确信法国人就要崩溃了。但并没有，凯勒曼将军摘下了他那顶饰有三色帽徽的帽子，把它举在剑上，大喊道：“法兰西万岁！”然后法国人开始唱起《Ça Ira》（会好起来的），他们的革命歌曲之一。但有趣的是，并不是《马赛曲》，显然没有
evidence that they sang that. No. So that may be another pointer to the fact that these are not the kind of the radicals, the cutting edge revolutionaries as yet. Right, exactly. I think the revolutionaries would love to rewrite this. This is Saint-Colottes singing the Marseillaise and indeed they do in subsequent years, but that's not true at all. So they're blasting away, the Prussians keep coming, the Prussians can't believe the
证据表明他们唱了这首歌。没有。所以这可能是另一个迹象，表明这些人还不是那种激进派、前沿的革命者。没错，完全正确。我想革命者们很愿意改写这段历史。这就是无套裤汉在唱《马赛曲》，而且他们在随后的几年里确实也这么做了，但当时完全不是这样。所以他们炮火连天，普鲁士人不断前进，普鲁士人简直不敢相信法国人竟然充满了干劲和活力，然后基本上普鲁士人动摇了，不伦瑞克说：“把他们叫回来，够了。”而法国人顶住了所有的逆境和期望，因为他们在战争刚开始时表现得实在是太糟糕了。
French are so full of vim and vigour and then basically the Prussians waver and Brunswick says, call them back, call them enough. And the French against all the odds and all expectations because they performed so abysmally at the beginning of the war. They have actually, they haven't quite won, but they have survived to fight another day. So it's kind of scraping a result in the final match of a group round in the World Cup. Kind of a bit like that. I think it is a bit like that, but after you've...
他们实际上——虽然没有彻底获胜，但他们活了下来，以便改日再战。所以这有点像在世界杯小组赛的最后一场比赛中勉强逼平出线。有点像那样。我想这确实有点像那样，但前提是你在……
It's the draw that you need that keeps you alive in the group, I think is what it is. But that's because it's come unexpectedly. It's fated as a great victory. It's fated as a great victory. Exactly. That's exactly what it is. The Prussians actually have killed more Frenchmen than the French have killed Prussians. But for the first time the Prussians have been stopped. They haven't been able to dislodge the French and
这正是让你在小组赛中得以存活的平局，我想这就是它的意义所在。但这之所以如此，是因为它来得出乎意料。它被塑造成了一场伟大的胜利。它被塑造成了一场伟大的胜利。完全正确。事实正是如此。实际上，普鲁士人杀死的法国人比法国人杀死的普鲁士人还要多。但这是普鲁士人第一次被阻击。他们没能把法国人赶下阵地，
their reactions to the two sides could not be more different. So the Prussians are absolutely gutted. They can't believe it. Doesn't Goethe, he makes a famous comment in a very grandiloquent way saying that this is, what is it? Something like, in a very grandiloquent way, saying that this is, what is it? Something like, gentlemen, you have witnessed the dawning of a new age. I felt you were gearing up to do him as Jeremy Corbyn there, which would have been a shame. So Goethe says, there's a wonderful scene. It's the great vanity of great writers. He says, they all sat alone around this fire.
而双方的反应可以说是截然不同。所以普鲁士人感到彻底泄气。他们简直不敢相信。歌德不是发表了一个著名的评论吗，用一种非常浮夸的语气说这是，什么来着？类似这样的，用非常浮夸的语气说，这是，什么来着？类似于：先生们，你们见证了一个新时代的曙光。我当时觉得你正准备把他模仿成杰里米·科尔宾，那可就太遗憾了。所以歌德说——这里有一个美妙的场景。这就是伟大作家的巨大虚荣心。他说，他们都独自围坐在火堆旁。
They're all really miserable. They couldn't meet each other's eye. And he says, everybody asked me what I thought about the events of the day, as, and I quote, my little sayings had often interested or amused our little company. And you think what an unsufferable boy he must have been to all the other soldiers. So he said to everybody, from this place and from this day forth, commences a new era in the world's history, and you can all say you are present at its birth. Now, so I'll tell you something.
他们都痛苦不堪。他们甚至不敢直视对方的眼睛。他说，每个人都问我对当天的事件有什么看法，因为，引述他的话，“我的妙语常常引起我们这个小圈子的兴趣或取悦大家”。你会觉得，对其他所有士兵来说，他当时一定是个令人难以忍受的家伙。所以他对每个人说：“从这个地方起，从今天起，世界历史上的一个新纪元开始了，你们都可以说你们见证了它的诞生。”现在，我来告诉你一件事。
I don't believe he did say that. I think that's far too good to be true. And he writes this a considerable time afterwards. So I'm suspicious of Goethe here. I think he's playing fast and loose with the, the facts. Cause it's too good of a line. That's what writers do, Dominic. That's what they do.
我不相信他说过这话。我认为这好得有点失真了。而且这是他在相当长一段时间之后才写下来的。所以我对这里的歌德持怀疑态度。我认为他在对事实进行艺术加工。因为这台词太好了。作家就是这样的，多米尼克，这就是他们的作风。
It is what they do. Anyway, for the French, because it's too good a lie. That's what writers do, Dominic. It is what they do. Anyway, for the French, this is massive. So there's a peasant soldier who writes to his father and he says, been electrified with a new courage that will make despots tremble. Oh, liberty, oh, equality, oh, my country. What a wonderful transformation. So I listen to Theo. I mean, if peasants are writing like that after the battle, then maybe
他们确实会这样。无论怎样，对法国人来说——因为这是一个太好的谎言。作家就是这样的，多米尼克。他们就是这样。不管怎样，对于法国人来说，这意义重大。所以有一个农民士兵写信给他的父亲，他说：“浑身充满了新的勇气，这勇气将使暴君们颤抖。哦，自由！哦，平等！哦，我的祖国！多么美妙的转变啊。”所以，听着，提奥。我的意思是，如果农民在战后写出这样的信，那么也许
Goethe is saying that kind of thing. Maybe Tom. I mean, maybe they're all, you know, massive effusions. They all feel that this is Titanic. I don't know. I just- Yeah, no, fair. That's fair.
歌德也说过类似的话。也许吧，汤姆。我的意思是，也许他们所有人，你知道的，都有着巨大的情感宣泄。他们都觉得这是天崩地裂般的。我不知道。是的，好吧，这倒也是。这很公平。
So lots of people say, gosh, this is a tremendous victory for the, for the new Republic, for our revolutionary virtue. And when, of course, when the news reaches the convention, they're all waving their hats in the air and delighted. And they say absolutely brilliant. History has begun again. It is a new chapter in the story of the human race. And I've got a question, which is that the news reaches Paris after
所以很多人说：“天哪，这对新共和国、对我们的革命美德来说是一场巨大的胜利。”当消息传到国民公会时，每个人都高兴得在空中挥舞着帽子。他们说，绝对太棒了。历史重新开始了。这是人类故事中的一个新篇章。我有一个问题，那就是消息传到巴黎时，
the monarchy has been abolished. Is there a feeling that this victory has been won because France is now a republic? Do you think there's something like that? Yeah, we've got rid of the king and the traitors. And immediately we start winning. Yeah, as soon as we took those blokes into the courtyards of various prisons and dispense summary justice, and as soon as we locked the king up in the temple fortress, surprise, surprise, we start winning battles, you know, quadrat demonstrandum, the king was a traitor and was undermining the war efforts. And that is what happened with the first democracy when Athens establishes its democracy having
君主制已经被废除了。人们是否会觉得，这场胜利之所以能够赢得，是因为法国现在是一个共和国？你觉得有这种感觉吗？是的，我们摆脱了国王和叛徒。然后我们立刻就开始获胜了。是的，正如我们把那些家伙带到各个监狱的庭院并进行即决审判，以及正如我们把国王锁在圣殿堡垒里一样，不出所料，我们开始赢得战斗了。显而易见（Quod erat demonstrandum），国王是个叛徒，一直在破坏战争努力。而这正是第一民主制发生的情况：当雅典在驱逐了暴君之后建立起民主制时，他们立即就开始赢得战役，想必人们是会意识到这一点的。也许这是历史铁律，汤姆，或者这只是一个巧合。无论如何，好吧，确实如此，因为在……因为他们在共和国宣告成立之前实际上就已经赢得了战役。对。好吧，这就像是，他们其实并没有赢得战役。
thrown out its tyrants, they immediately start winning battles and presumably people would have been aware of this. Maybe this is an ironclad lore of history, Tom, or maybe it's just a coincidence. Anyway, well, it is because by, because they actually win the battle before the proclamation of the Republic. Right. Yeah. Well, it's like, they don't really win the battle.
这只是一场平局。所以，你原本会以为这会让他们所有人充满极大的……你知道的，友爱、和谐感。得了吧，让我们埋掉意识形态的斧头，为共同的利益共同努力吧。那你就大错特错了。因为事实上从一开始——我知道你不会错的，汤姆，我知道你很清楚接下来会发生什么。
It's just a draw. So the, you would think that this would fill them all with great, um, you know, Bonhomie harm, a sense of harmony. Yeah. Come on, let's bury that in the ideological hatchet and work together for the common good. You would be wrong because actually from the beginning, I know you wouldn't be wrong, Tom, I know you know that what's going to happen.
国民公会充斥着令人难以置信的派系斗争。基本上有三个阵营，也许我们不需要花上永恒的时间来讨论他们，但还是需要一点背景。首先，你有布里索和吉伦特派。所以如果你还记得，这些其实并不是一个巴黎政党。他们是像波尔多这样的大省份城市的政党。因为吉伦特这个名字就是从那来的，不是吗？就是那个北部河岸。
The convention is riven by the most unbelievable faction fighting. So basically there are three blocks and maybe we don't need to spend an eternity discussing them but a little bit of context. First of all, you have Briceau and the Girondins. So if you remember, these are not really a Parisian party. They're a party of the kind of big provincial cities like Bordeaux. Because that's where Girondins comes from, isn't it? It's the Northern bank.
完全正确。他们都在罗兰夫人的公寓里聚餐，互相交流着妙语。他们在国民公会里基本上拥有大约150名代表，这些人会一直支持他们，而且他们还可以拉拢一些独立派来为他们争取多数席位。然后你有中间的大多数人。他们被称为，他们要么被称为“沼泽派”，这听起来非常，你知道的，我可不想成为沼泽派的一部分。
Exactly. They're all hanging around having dinner with Madame Roland in her apartment and swapping witty aphorisms. And they've basically got about 150 deputies in the convention that will always support them and they can call on some independents to give them a majority. Then you have the great mass of people who are kind of in the middle. They are called the, they're either called the marsh, which seems to very, you know, it's not very, I wouldn't want to be part of the marsh.
中间派人士。那是什么？中间派爸爸们。中间派。哦，对了。非常不错。是的。
Les Pères sont tristes. What's that? Sainte Tristade. The center. Oh, right. It's a very, you know, it's not very, I wouldn't want to be part of the marsh. Leper centrist. What's that? Centrist dads. The cent. Oh, right. Okay. Very good. Yeah.
好吧，他们其实不是中间派爸爸，对吧？因为现在所有人都左转了，但他们就是沼泽派，或者人们称他们为平原派，因为他们坐在大厅中间，基本上，你知道的，他们可能会倾向于这一边或那一边，但在此时，他们通常受吉伦特派的左右。然后你有远左翼的激进分子。他们被称为“山岳派”（Montagnards），他们坐在大厅左侧的高处，因此得名山岳派。他们大约有200人，150到200人。
Well, they're not really centrist dads are they? Cause everybody's now on the left, but they are the marsh or the, the plane people call them, because they sit in the middle of the hall and they basically, you know, they can lean one way or the other, but at this point they are generally swayed by the Girondins. And then you have the radicals on the far left. They're called the mountain, the Montagnards, and they sit high up in the left of the hall, hence the mountain. There's about 200 of them, 150 to 200.
他们非常具有巴黎特色，罗伯斯庇尔、丹东、马拉。所有这些出名的人，都是人们听说过的人。他们现在控制了雅各宾俱乐部，因为吉伦特派懒得去那里。他们还吸引了两类人：非常年轻的代表，更有可能成为山岳派，他们往往更加急躁、更有野心、更加激进。这是自古以来一直延续到今天的一种现象的首次显现，即年轻人倾向于支持左翼更激进的解决方案。没错。
They're very Parisian, Robespierre, Danton, Marat. All the famous guys, the ones that people have heard of. They dominate the Jacobin club now because the Jean-Modan don't bother turning up to it. And they also appeal to two groups, very young deputies and much more likely to be Montagnard, they're likely to be kind of more impatient, more ambitious, more radical. And this is the first manifestation of a sense that runs right the way up to the present day that the young are inclined to back more radical solutions on the left. Right.
我的意思是，这是它的首次显现。我认为这绝对正确。有趣的是，他们还吸引了那些来自非常偏僻地方的代表，他们基本上是自己村里唯一的激进分子，因此感到四面楚歌。当他们到达巴黎时，他们很高兴能找到志同道合的朋友。而这种四面楚歌的处境让他们变得更加激进，我猜。这对他们来说一定非常令人兴奋。哦，是的。我认为有一种强烈的兴奋感，而且山岳派，
I mean, this is the first manifestation of it. I think that's absolutely right. They also appeal to deputies, interestingly, who come from very isolated kind of places who've basically been the one radical in their village, who therefore feel very embattled. And when they arrive in Paris, they are delighted to find friends. And that they're being embattled has made them more radical, I guess. That must be very exciting for them. Oh yeah. I think there's a definite sense of excitement and of the Montagnards,
我们现在认为他们是在罗伯斯庇尔、丹东和马拉的三巨头统治下的政党。我的意思是，他们真的是法国大革命的三巨头，不是吗？你甚至可以说是一个执政同盟。但他们并不像一个执政同盟。他们实际上根本合不来。好吧，罗伯斯庇尔讨厌马拉，不是吗？罗伯斯庇尔鄙视马拉。
basically now we think of them as being control, a party ruled by the triumvirate of Robespierre, Danton and Marat. I mean, they really are the big three of the French revolution, aren't they? The triumvirate, you might almost say. But they're not like a triumvirate of Robespierre, Danton and Marat. I mean, they really are the big three of the French Revolution, aren't they? The triumvirate, you might almost say. But they're not like a triumvirate. They actually don't really get on with each other. Well, Robespierre hates Marat, doesn't he? Robespierre despises Marat.
根本不理睬他，甚至拒绝跟他有任何瓜葛。我想是因为罗伯斯庇尔太冷冰冰了，他非常在意自己的假发和那种骨感。他的皮肤很好。是的。而马拉不戴假发，皮肤极差，非常糟糕，整天泡在浴缸里。
Won't have anything to do with him, like refuses to have anything to do with him. I think because Robespierre is so chilly and he's so worried about his wig and his kind of boniness. He's got great skin. Yeah. And Marat doesn worried about his wig and his kind of bone-in-ness. He's got great skin. Yeah. And Mara doesn't wear a wig, has terrible skin, awful, sits in baths.
没错。丹东和马拉的皮肤都很差，不是吗？丹东忙着大口大口地塞鸡腿。是的。而且还收受装有现金的牛皮纸信封。马拉则整天大喊大叫要杀光所有人，表现得非常极端等等。所以实际上这三人互相都相当猜忌，他们并不是一个紧密团结的合作单元。我想另一个问题是，这些是我们在今天能够识别的那种意识形态政党吗？我的回答依然是，不。山岳派和吉伦特派在外部观察家看来似乎有太多的共同点。你知道的，他们都是共和党人。他们都信仰战争，诸如此类。我认为有两个差异是非常重要的。其中之一就是对“人民”的概念。吉伦特派，因为他们是来自波尔多的商人阶层之类的人。他们基本上认为像他们这样的人应该来领导革命。
Right. Both Danton and Mara have terrible skin, don't they? Danton is too busy like stuffing himself with like chicken legs. Yeah. And also taking brown envelopes of cash. Mara is just shouting about like killing everybody and being very over the top and stuff. So actually they're all quite suspicious of each other, these three, they don't work together as a tight knit unit. I guess the other question is, are these kind of ideological
你知道的，那些去文学沙龙互相背诵诗歌的人。是的。然而罗伯斯庇尔和山岳派，他们对此持怀疑态度。他们是地道的民粹主义者。他们全心全意为了普通民众，为了街头的美德。巴黎人民才最懂。是的。一个穷苦的街头流浪儿比一个，你知道的，要懂得多得多——这非常卢梭，不是吗？这非常卢梭。这非常——汤姆，这非常基督教，不是吗？
political parties of the kind that we would recognize today? And the answer again, I think, no, the Montagnard and the Girondins to outside observers seem to have loads in common. You know, they're all Republicans. They all believe in the war, all of that stuff. There are two things I think that are really important, the differences. So one of them is the idea of the people. The Girondins, because they're kind of merchant class from Bordeaux and stuff. They basically think that people like them should be running the revolution.
难道不是吗？我很惊讶你居然没这么说。当然。但我的意思是，你知道的，这就是我对法国大革命中一切事物的看法。
You know, people who go to literary salons and quote poetry to each other. Yeah. Whereas Robespierre and the Montagnard, they think they're suspicious of that. They are pure populists. They're all about the common people, the virtues of the streets. They're the people of Paris know better. Yeah. A poor urchin knows much better than a, you know, it's that kind of-
这倒也是。这确实如此。这是不言而喻的。另一件可能没那么基督教的事情是，山岳派要热衷暴力得多。不，你看，我认为那相当基督教。有美德的暴力。是的。好吧。十字军东征，审判——有美德的暴力。是的。
It's Rousseau, isn't it? It's very Rousseau. It's very Rousseau. It's very, Tom is very Christian. Is it not? I'm surprised you didn't say that. Of course. But I mean, you know, this is what I think about everything in the French revolution.
十字军东征，审判。好吧。我们就假设你对什么都这么看吧。不，我不是对什么都这么看，因为很明显你可以有非基督教的暴力，但我认为“暴力是美德的”这种观念。是的。这就是它的来源。
That's true. That's true. That goes without saying. The other thing that's perhaps a little less Christian is the Montagnards are much keen on violence. No, but you see, I think that is pretty Christian. Virtuous violence. Yeah. Okay. Crusades, inquis is pretty Christian. Virtuous violence. Yeah.
正如你所预料的那样，因为这是，你知道的，18世纪的法国，对暴力美德的展示随处可见。是的，有道理。所以很显然，展示美德暴力最明显的方式就是九月大屠杀，山岳派对此完全赞成。但吉伦特派对九月大屠杀其实有些纠结。罗伯斯庇尔则认为这一切棒极了。
Crusades, inquisitions. Okay. Let's just assume you think it of everything. No, I don't think of everything because obviously you can have non-Christian violence, but I think the idea of violence being virtuous. Yeah. That's where it's coming from. Yes.
十字军东征，宗教裁判所。好吧。我们就假设你考虑到了所有事情。不，我没有考虑到所有事情，因为很明显会存在非基督教的暴力，但我认为暴力具有美德这种观念。是的。这就是它的来源。是的。
As you'd expect because this is, you know, 18th century France and displays of violent virtue are everywhere. Yeah, fair enough. So obviously the most visible sign of virtuous violence has been the September massacres, which the Montagnards were all for. But the Girondins are actually a little bit conflicted about the September massacres. They've been, Robespierre thought all this was brilliant.
正如你所料，因为这是18世纪的法国，彰显暴力美德的现象随处可见。是的，说的也是。因此，显而易见，最具代表性的暴力美德迹象就是九月大屠杀，山岳派对此举双手赞成。但吉伦特派其实对九月大屠杀有些矛盾。他们一直……罗伯斯庇尔认为这一切棒极了。
He loved the attack on the Tuileries. He loved the September massacres. He thinks the fact that the Girondins are being a bit squeamish shows that they are suspects, counter-revolutionary and all that kind of thing. Tom, I can see you itching to say something. What is so interesting and fascinating about this is that you see for the first time the manifestation of political trends that just repeat and repeat and repeat. And surely what is happening with the Girondins and the Montagnards is the notion that people
他喜欢攻打杜伊勒里宫。他喜欢九月大屠杀。他认为吉伦特派有点过分谨慎，这说明他们有嫌疑，是反革命之流。汤姆，我看得出来你急于说点什么。这其中最有趣、最吸引人的一点是，你首次看到了政治倾向的表现，它们会不断地重复、重复、再重复。当然，吉伦特派和山岳派之间发生的事情，正是那种认为
on the left can be outflanked to their left and therefore are always moving leftwards to try and avoid that. And so the radicals of one month can suddenly find themselves the reactionaries of the next month. And it means that there's an impetus always to go further and further. Whether you are backing, you know, the people are always right, or whether you are saying virtue is manifest in violence. If you start saying, I'm not sure about that, then immediately you are a reactionary. That is a trend that you see again and again and again, I mean, throughout
左翼人士可能在他们的左翼被超越，因此总是向左移动以试图避免这种情况的观念。因此，一个月的激进分子可能会突然发现自己成为下一个月的反动派。这意味着总有一种推动力要走得更远。无论你是在支持，你知道的，人民永远是正确的，还是在说美德体现在暴力中。如果你开始说，我对这一点不太确定，那么你立刻就成了反动派。这种趋势你会一次又一次地看到，我的意思是，贯穿于
the history of 19th century socialism, and right the way up to the present day. Absolutely. You're totally right. That sort of ratchet effect. And in fact, I was just thinking if somebody missed a couple of episodes of the series, you know, if they'd skipped, they'd be like, hold on, those people were on the far left two episodes ago. Now you're describing them as, you know, counter revolutionary reactionaries. Because as you say, the center of gravity is always moving leftwards. What's on the Jean-Rendon's mind as well, by the way, is the fact that during the September massacres, there is some evidence that Robespierre and Marat
19世纪社会主义的历史，一直延续到今天。绝对的。你完全正确。那种类似棘轮的效应。事实上，我刚刚在想，如果有人漏掉了这个系列的几集，你知道的，如果他们跳过了，他们会觉得，等等，两集前那些人还在极左翼。现在你把他们描述为，你知道的，反革命的反动派。因为正如你所说，重力中心一直在向左移动。让-罗兰的心思也在想，顺便说一句，事实上，在九月大屠杀期间，有一些证据表明罗伯斯庇尔和马拉
had actually toyed with the idea of killing them too. So Robespierre, on the day the massacres had broken out, the 2nd of September, he had been giving a speech in the commune, the sort of city council of Paris, in which he had said that the Girondins were secretations of the Prussians and perfidious intrigues working against French liberty. Now, anyone who's listened to the whole of this series will know how bonkers that is because the Girondins were the key people in this idea of the mask of patriotism, that the more patriotic you appear to be, the more likely it is that you are in fact a traitor. So they, the commune had issued a warrant for some of the general and Anne's arrest, which was never carried out. But Briceau and Roland and these people, they know about this and they say, my God, Robespierre
其实也曾动过杀他们的念头。所以罗伯斯庇尔在大屠杀爆发的那天，也就是9月2日，曾在公社（相当于巴黎市议会）发表过一次演讲，在演讲中他说吉伦特派是普鲁士人的秘密特务和阻碍法国自由的阴谋诡计。现在，听完整部系列的人都会知道这有多疯狂，因为吉伦特派是“爱国主义面具”这一理念的关键人物，你表现得越爱国，你实际上就越可能是叛徒。所以他们，公社对一些吉伦特派下达了逮捕令，但从未执行。但布里索和罗兰这些人，他们知道这件事，并且他们说，天哪，罗伯斯庇尔
wants to kill us. He wanted to kill us and it's just luck that he didn't and so they become convinced what they are now convinced. That basically it's kill or be killed so in that sense right from the moment the convention meets which is twenty first of september. It's not like a normal parliament that we would know today because there is no sense of pluralism. There's no sense that they're going to be having discussions and you win some, you lose some or that kind of thing. No sense of a loyal opposition. None. So by definition, this is about virtue versus corruption.
想杀了我们。他想杀了我们，他没得逞只是因为运气好，所以他们坚信了他们现在所确信的。基本上这就是你死我活，所以在这种意义上，从国民公会开会的那一刻起，也就是9月21日。它不像我们今天所知道的普通议会，因为根本没有多元主义的概念。没有任何他们会进行讨论的意识，你赢一些，你输一些诸如此类。没有忠诚反对派的概念。一点也没有。所以根据定义，这是美德与腐败的较量。
It's about the Republic versus counter revolution. To be a dissenter is to be a traitor. And so I think from the very first moment they take their seats, it is obvious there is absolutely going to be a showdown and that whoever loses that will probably end up on the guillotine. And if you had to put your money on somebody at this point, September, 1792, you would probably put it on the gendarme. They have a bit more of a majority.
这是共和国与反革命的较量。持异议就是叛徒。所以我认为从他们就座的那第一分钟起，就很明显将会有一次摊牌，无论谁输了最终都可能会走上断头台。如果你在这个时候，1792年9月，非得把赌注押在某个人身上，你可能会押在吉伦特派身上。他们拥有更多的多数席位。
They have a bit more self-confidence they control the presidency of the convention and So right from the beginning with a September massacre so fresh in their minds They say right that settle this once and for all let's do this and right away. They go for the Montagnards throats Wow, well, I think that is too much excitement for one half of an episode, so I think we should take a break here and when we come back we will see what the upshot of this Girondin attempt to take down the Montagnards actually is. Hello, welcome back. We left you at a moment of high drama.
他们更有自信，他们控制了国民公会的主席团，所以从一开始，九月大屠杀的记忆还在他们脑海中挥之不去，他们就说，好，让我们一劳永逸地解决这个问题，让我们这么干，而且要马上干。他们直奔山岳派的喉咙。哇，好吧，我认为这对于一集的一半来说刺激过头了，所以我想我们应该在这里休息一下，当我们回来时，我们将看看吉伦特派试图打倒山岳派的结果到底是什么。你好，欢迎回来。我们把你们留在一个充满戏剧性的时刻。
The Girondins are about to take on the Montagnards in the national convention. Dominic put people out of their misery. What happens? So they make their move, Tom, two days after the Battle of Valmy, 22nd of September. The convention's only really been up and running for a day and a bit. And a dozen speakers, one after the other, Girond down get up and lay into the Montagnard and they want their plan is to convince the convention the Montagnard traitors and they should be arrested and you know thrown out of the convention. They say they are anarchists, they are murderers, they are levelers interestingly.
吉伦特派即将在国民公会中与山岳派较量。多米尼克，给大家解解闷吧。发生了什么？所以他们采取了行动，汤姆，在瓦尔米战役两天后，即9月22日。国民公会真正开张运转才一天多一点。十几个发言者，一个接一个，吉伦特派站起来猛烈抨击山岳派，他们的计划是让国民公会相信山岳派是叛徒，他们应该被逮捕，你知道的，被赶出国民公会。他们说他们是无政府主义者，他们是杀人犯，有趣的是，他们是平权派。
Oh right. A word that we very familiar to people in about 17th century England. But don't they also compare them to Caesar, Crassus and Pompey? They do. The first triumph in ancient Rome. They do. They're very promiscuous with their historical analogies. I think it's fair to say, cause Briso says on the one hand, he says
哦，对。这个词对大约17世纪英格兰的人来说非常熟悉。但他们不也将他们与凯撒、克拉苏和庞培进行比较吗？他们确实这么做了。古罗马的第一次凯旋。他们确实这么做了。我觉得可以说他们对历史类比非常滥用，因为布里索一方面说
they're the Hydra of anarchy. They want to level everything. And then the other hand, he says Robespierre, Marat and Danton are the new Crassus, Caesar and Pompey exactly as you said, and Robespierre and Danton say, Oh, this is absolute nonsense. You know, I don't even like him. I have no, we're not, we're not trying to run for it at all. Mara, he obviously is, this is, he's making his debut effectively
他们是无政府状态的九头蛇。他们想把一切都拉平。然后另一方面，他说罗伯斯庇尔、马拉和丹东是新的克拉苏、凯撒和庞培，正如你刚才所说，罗伯斯庇尔和丹东说，哦，这完全是胡说八道。你知道的，我甚至都不喜欢他。我没有，我们不是，我们根本没想参与竞选。马拉，他显然是，这是他实际上在
in frontline politics. Wow. And what a way to do it. And he says, I'm not a traitor, but if you're accusing me of trying to set up a dictatorship, well, I'll be frank with you. I think a dictatorship should be brilliant. I'd love a dictatorship. And he said, he pulls a gun out of his pocket and he holds it to his own head. And he says, if you vote to condemn me, I will blow out my brains in front of you.
一线政治中首次亮相。哇。好一种亮相方式。他说，我不是叛徒，但如果你指控我企图建立独裁统治，好吧，我跟你直说吧。我认为独裁统治应该很棒。我很喜欢独裁统治。他说，他从口袋里掏出一把枪，指着自己的脑袋。他说，如果你投票谴责我，我当着你的面把脑浆崩出来。
Rather than threatening to blow out the brains of a giron d'aspere. I guess so. People are very impressed by this. They say, well, this obviously shows the mayor is a tremendous fellow. And the result of this is that there's a, they're not kicked out. So the Montagnard have made a bit of a mistake here. They've, I was about to say they've wounded but not killed their opponent. They've barely even wounded them. Yeah. I mean, if you're going to shoot at the king, you better kill him. Exactly. So it is clear from this point that this feud is only ever going to get worse. And a few weeks go by, the Girondins d'armes basically are sort of constantly niggling at the
而不是威胁要崩掉一个吉伦特派的脑浆。我想是的。人们对此印象深刻。他们说，这显然表明马拉是个了不起的家伙。而这导致的结果是，他们没有被驱逐。所以山岳派在这里犯了一点错误。他们，我正要说他们打伤了但没有杀死对手。他们甚至都算不上打伤了对手。是的。我的意思是，如果你要向国王开枪，你最好把他打死。没错。所以从这一点很清楚，这种恩怨只会愈演愈烈。几个星期过去了，吉伦特派基本上一直在
Montagnard but never bringing them down. Also the gérons d'armes, as time goes by, they're actually beginning to lose a bit of support from the plane, from the independent people, because the independent people actually are a bit sick of this. And also the gérons d'armes are quite corrupt and they're very overbearing and they're very kind of hungry for power and bossy. They've got all their dinner parties haven't they? They go to their dinner parties. High-fleet dinner parties. Yeah, exactly.
对山岳派挑刺，但从未打倒他们。而且随着时间的推移，吉伦特派其实也开始失去来自平原派、独立人士的一些支持，因为独立人士实际上有点厌烦这一切了。而且吉伦特派相当腐败，他们非常专横，非常渴望权力且好管闲事。他们办了所有的晚宴，不是吗？他们去参加他们的晚宴。高规格的晚宴。是的，没错。
Inviting the normal people. Right, and if you're just a bog standard deputy from provincial France, you're sick of being like lectured by Briceau and having him slacking off the Montagnard and stuff, you just become very impatient with all this. And I think the genre don't know this. So towards the end of October They decide to have another go and this time they will just go for Rob Spear and they'll go for him personally and they get a newspaper editor called Jean Baptiste Louvet
邀请普通人。对，如果你只是法国各省一个平庸的议员，你厌倦了被布里索说教，听他贬低山岳派之类的事情，你对这一切就会变得非常不耐烦。我想吉伦特派也知道这一点。所以在10月底左右，他们决定再试一次，这一次他们只针对罗伯斯庇尔，他们要针对他个人，他们找了一个叫让-巴蒂斯特·卢韦的报纸编辑
to stand up and accuse Rob Spear of trying to make himself dictator of Having a personality cult now again. They reach for a Roman parallel interesting course they do so Louvet deliberately models his speech on Cicero unveiling the Catiline conspiracy. And of course that's the analogy that everybody knows. They've all grown up, they've all done it at school. It's been a long time. How long will you abuse our patience, Robespierre?
站出来指责罗伯斯庇尔企图让自己成为独裁者，搞个人崇拜。现在他们又搬出了罗马的平行对比，很有趣，他们当然这么做了。所以卢韦故意模仿西塞罗揭露喀提那阴谋的演讲。当然，那是每个人都知道的类比。他们都长大了，都在学校里学过这个。这已经是很久以前的事了。罗伯斯庇尔，你要滥用我们的耐心到什么时候？
All of that stuff, exactly. And Louvet says, come on, France has a choice. There are only two parties and France must choose. There is the party of us, the Girondins, we're the party of philosophers. And on the other hand, there is the mountain. They're the party of murderers. Put it like that. Yeah, exactly.
诸如此类，完全是这样。卢韦说，来吧，法国面临着抉择。只有两个党派，法国必须做出选择。有我们党，吉伦特派，我们是哲学家党。另一方面，有山岳派。他们是杀人党。就这样。是的，绝对是。
If I was facing attack from the Prussians and I had to choose one of those two parties to represent me, I definitely wouldn't choose the philosophers. But you know who's there for this? Well, you do know, because I know you've got the notes. But also I know this because I'm a big fan of his, is the great poet William Wordsworth. He's basically on his gap year, isn't he? Yeah, he is. He's on a holiday. Well, he's not on holiday. He's graduated and doesn't know what to do with himself.
如果我面临普鲁士人的进攻，而我必须从这两个代表我的党派中选择一个，我绝对不会选择哲学家。但你知道谁在现场吗？好吧，你确实知道，因为我知道你有笔记。但我也知道这一点，因为我是他的超级粉丝，那就是伟大的诗人威廉·华兹华斯。他基本上是在过间隔年，对吧？是的，他是。他在度假。好吧，他不是在度假。他毕业了，不知道该拿自己怎么办。
So he's gone off to France, supposedly to improve his knowledge of French. But actually he's having an affair with a woman in Orléans, got her pregnant. That would, that would improve your French though, surely? Yes it would. Give us a bit of poetry, Tom. I know you love a bit of Wordsworth. When a dead pause ensued and no one stirred in silence of all present from his seat, Louvay walked single through the avenue and took his station in the tribune saying, I, Robespierre,
所以他去了法国，据说是为了提高他的法语水平。但实际上他正在奥尔良和一个女人有染，还让她怀孕了。那，那确实能提高你的法语水平吧，肯定的？是的，确实能。给我们来点诗吧，汤姆。我知道你很喜欢华兹华斯的诗。当全场陷入死一般的寂静，在所有人静默之中没有人动弹时，卢韦从他的座位上独自穿过通道，在讲坛上站定，说道：“我，罗伯斯庇尔，
accuse thee. Now that line is actually a bit confusing, isn't it? Because it makes it sound like Rose is claiming to be exactly. I don't want to diss Wordsworth, one of our greatest ever poets. Let's just let himself down there with his lack of clarity. So this is in the prelude, which he writes much later when he's become a counter revolutionary in a massive reactionary. Shall I, shall I carry on? Do. We'd love that.
控告你。”现在那句台词其实有点令人困惑，不是吗？因为这听起来像是罗伯斯庇尔在声称自己是……完全是这样。我不想贬低华兹华斯，我们最伟大的诗人之一。他在那里由于缺乏清晰度而让自己有点失水准了。所以这是在《序曲》中，那是他很久以后成为一个反革命分子和一个巨大的反动派时写的。我该，我该继续吗？请吧。我们很乐意听。
A bit more poetry? Yeah, I love it. Well is known the inglorious issue of that charge and how he who had launched the startling thunderbolt, so that's Louvet, the one bold man whose voice the attack had sounded was left without a follower to discharge his perilous duty and retired lamenting that heaven's best aid is wasted upon men who to themselves are false, which is a long way of saying that Lévé's attack doesn't work and he doesn't get the support that he'd been expecting. And it's all a bit of an embarrassment and a let down.
再来点诗？是的，我很喜欢。众所周知，那次指控没有好结果，那个发起惊人雷霆一击的人——也就是卢韦，那个发出进攻声音的勇敢的人，竟然没有一个追随者来执行他危险的职责，只能退下并哀叹上天的最佳援助竟浪费在那些对自己不忠的人身上，这换言之就是说卢韦的攻击没有起作用，他没有得到他所期望的支持。这一切都有些尴尬和令人失望。
It is an embarrassment. Exactly. Wordsworth in a very convoluted way is quite right. And actually Rob Spier completely wins the day. So a week later Robespierre, he buys his time and then he makes his response. And he says, I have encouraged violence, he says, but I did it because it was the only way to save the country. And he says to everybody, do you want to have a revolution without a revolution? I mean, we have to, you know,
这确实很尴尬。没错。华兹华斯以一种非常曲折的方式说得非常对。事实上，罗伯斯庇尔大获全胜。所以一周后，罗伯斯庇尔养精蓄锐，然后做出了回应。他说，我鼓励了暴力，他说，但我这么做是因为这是拯救国家的唯一途径。他对所有人说，你们想要一场没有革命的革命吗？我的意思是，我们必须，你知道的，
I did it and I was right to do it. Because people may remember when we talked about the guillotine that Rospierre was against capital punishment, but he is now saying that the travails of the Republic are such that the real crime would not be to support the elimination of those who threaten France and the nation. And as we discussed in the September massacres episode, a majority clearly agree with that. They think we're at war. You know, we've always executed people.
我做了，而且我这么做是对的。因为人们可能还记得，当我们讨论断头台时，罗伯斯庇尔是反对死刑的，但他现在说，共和国的苦难是如此深重，以至于真正的罪行将不是支持消灭那些威胁法国和国家的人。正如我们在九月大屠杀那一集里讨论的那样，大多数人显然都同意这一点。他们认为我们在打仗。你知道的，我们一直都在处决人。
It's not like public executions and the public display of violence is a novelty. It's completely reasonable for us to use violent measures to preserve the Republic. And so Rob Speyer wins the day. He gets torrents of applause in the convention. Briceau and the Girondins are kind of fuming. They're sort of like sort of cartoon characters kind of clenching their fists with braid. You pesky Montagnard kind of on the benches. And Briceau writes to du Murier and he says, this is absolutely intolerable.
这不像是公开处决和公开展示暴力是什么新鲜事。我们采取暴力手段来维护共和国是完全合理的。于是罗伯斯庇尔大获全胜。他在国民公会中赢得了如潮的掌声。布里索和吉伦特派气急败坏。他们有点像漫画里那种咬牙切齿、挥舞着拳头的人，坐在长椅上喊着：“你们这些讨厌的山岳派。”布里索写信给迪穆里埃，他说，这绝对是不可容忍的。
He says, I spend all my time fighting these miserable anarchists. That's a direct quote. When I should be concentrating on the uprising of the entire planet. I mean, which is a bonkers thing to say, but quite Trotsky, isn't it? It's very Trotsky, but you can see why he's saying it because we're now six weeks after the Battle of Valmy. And since then, Tom, there have been some unbelievably dramatic scenes on the battlefield. Has Deumarie managed to invade Belgium,
他说，我把所有的时间都用来和这些可怜的无政府主义者战斗。这是一个直接引语。而我本应该集中精力应对整个星球的起义。我的意思是，这是一句疯狂的话，但非常像托洛茨基，不是吗？非常托洛茨基，但你能理解他为什么这么说，因为现在是瓦尔米战役后六周。从那以后，汤姆，战场上发生了一些令人难以置信的戏剧性场面。迪穆里埃成功入侵比利时了吗？
which you said was his long-term kind of plan? Excitingly, yes. Oh, bless him. So for once, somebody in the story has actually got what he wanted. So basically, here's what's happened. I know you love military history, Tom. The Prussians have been hanging around outside Valmy, pouring with rain after this kind of draw. And the Duke of Brunswick eventually says, right, listen, we don't want to be cut off from our supplies. We're obviously not going to get to Paris. Let's cut our losses, head back towards Germany for the winter. So in scenes of great sort of degradation and misery, which kind of
你不是说那是他的长期计划吗？令人兴奋的是，是的。哦，谢天谢地。所以破天荒地，故事里的某个人终于得到了他想要的东西。基本上，事情是这样的，我知道你喜欢军事史，汤姆。普鲁士人在瓦尔米外面徘徊，在这样一场平局之后下着倾盆大雨。不伦瑞克公爵最终说，好吧，听着，我们不想被切断补给。我们显然去不了巴黎。让我们减少损失，冬天向德国方向撤退。所以在这种巨大的屈辱和悲惨的场景中，歌德曾对此进行过描写，他一路撤退，甚至一直退回到了莱茵河对岸。现在这真的很重要，因为这意味着，莱茵河西岸现在完全没有防御了，上面有德国的城市和城镇。
Goethe writes about, he withdraws all the way back and he even goes all the way back across the river Rhine. Now that really matters because what that means is that the, the Western bank of the Rhine is now completely undefended with German cities and towns on it. It is completely undefended from the French. So by late October, the French who are on their uppers a bit ago, and now advancing on German cities, places like Mainz,
它对法国人来说是完全不设防的。因此到10月下旬，不久前还处境艰难的法国人现在正向德国城市挺进，比如美因茨、
Worms, Frankfurt. And out of these German cities, the prince bishops and the electors and all of these bigwigs are kind of fleeing as fast as they can with all their kind of Germanic books and whatever, marzipan on carts. So this is the point of what Briceau is saying to de Mourier is that this is now an international revolution. Right. The world lies open before us because the French, by the way, in the long run, this
沃尔姆斯、法兰克福。从这些德国城市里，亲王主教们、选帝侯们和所有这些大人物们正带着他们所有的德式书籍和诸如手推车上的杏仁膏之类的东西，以最快的速度逃跑。所以这就是布里索对迪穆里埃所说的话的关键点，即这现在是一场国际革命。对。世界在我们面前敞开，因为法国人，顺便说一句，从长远来看，这将是欧洲历史上一个巨大的时刻，因为这基本上是德国身份和德国民族主义的诞生。
will be a massive moment in European history because it's basically the birth of German identity and German nationalism. Because loads of people had waited, couldn't wait for the French Revolution to get to Germany. When the revolution does turn up, they say, oh God, this is terrible. Well, these French people kind of living in our houses, looting all our stuff and bossing us around, and so you get the German identity, you can argue to some degree dates from this moment as a kind of political force. Anyway, the French don't just stop at the Rhine, they're advancing everywhere.
因为许多人一直在等待，迫不及待地想让法国革命来到德国。当革命真的出现时，他们说，哦天哪，这太可怕了。好吧，这些法国人住在我们的房子里，掠夺我们所有的东西，对我们颐指气使，所以你得到了德国身份，你可以说在某种程度上它始于这一时刻，作为一种政治力量。无论如何，法国人不仅止步于莱茵河，他们在各处推进。
So they invade the Swiss Federation. They're heading for Geneva. They invade Savoy and they take all the lands west of the Alps and they create a new department called Mont Blanc. They also seize the county of Nice. We always think of Nice as, I mean, most people think of it as French. It's actually been part of Savoy since 1388. And so all these kind of little medieval, uh, aberrations are being swallowed up by France and becoming part of France. So like Avignon as well had already gone. Yeah, Avignon, exactly.
所以他们入侵了瑞士联邦。他们正前往日内瓦。他们入侵萨伏伊，夺取了阿尔卑斯山以西的所有土地，并建立了一个名为“勃朗峰”的新省份。他们还占领了尼斯伯国。我们总是认为尼斯是，我的意思是，大多数人认为它是法国的。实际上它自1388年以来一直是萨伏伊的一部分。所以所有这些中世纪的小错误正在被法国吞并，并成为法国的一部分。就像阿维尼翁一样也已经归入了。是的，阿维尼翁，完全是这样。
But above all Belgium. So Duméry had always dreamed of this. Uh, he beats a small Austrian army at a place called Jemap, which is just south of Mont on the 6th of November. And the Austrians have to pull back. He takes Monts. He's in Brussels by the 14th of November. By the end of November.
但最重要的是比利时。所以迪穆里埃一直梦想着这一点。他在11月6日于蒙斯以南的热马普击败了一支小型奥地利军队。奥地利人被迫撤退。他占领了蒙斯。他在11月14日抵达布鲁塞尔。到11月底。
I mean, this is the extraordinary thing, the seesaw momentum. He has taken Liège and Antwerp and he is heading towards the borders of the Dutch Republic. And Dominic, by this point, there is a lot of singing of the Marseilles. Loads. Exactly. It accompanies the invasion, the victories, all kinds of things. I think this is the moment actually when you can say that patriotic revolutionary fervour
我的意思是，这是非同寻常的事情，跷跷板式的势头。他占领了列日和安特卫普，正朝着荷兰共和国的边境前进。而多米尼克，在这个时候，有很多唱《马赛曲》的声音。非常多。没错。它伴随着入侵、胜利，各种各样的东西。我认为这实际上是你可以说爱国革命热情诞生的时刻，
is born really, born in victory. This is the point at which you have patriotic festivals across France, sort of fest feasts and bonfires and people singing things like they're singing the Marseillaise in the streets. And again, it's a manifestation of the fact that now France is no longer a monarchy and is a republic, suddenly they're winning. Yeah, absolutely. But here's the thing, right? They're not just winning.
在胜利中诞生。这就是法国各地举行爱国节庆的时刻，某种节庆和篝火晚会，人们在街上唱着像《马赛曲》这样的歌曲。同样，这也是法国不再是君主国而是成为共和国的一个表现，突然之间他们赢了。是的，绝对是。但问题是，对吧？他们不仅仅是在赢。
They're winning victories now. And because the Prussians and the Austrians had basically not bargained for this, overextended themselves and not properly prepared. The French are now winning victories that are really unprecedented in the last few generations, victories that eclipse even the victories of Louis the 14th. And so deputies back in Paris are now beginning to ask themselves, well, where, where will we stop?
他们现在赢得了一场又一场的胜利。由于普鲁士人和奥地利人基本上没有料到这一点，过度扩张且没有做好充分准备。法国人现在取得的胜利在过去几代人中真的是史无前例的，这些胜利甚至黯淡了路易十四的胜利。因此，巴黎的议员们现在开始问自己，好吧，我们会在哪里停下？
Where would the revolution stop? Because of course they've always thought of it. There's not just a French nationalist project, but a universalist one. Well, again, this is what Briceau is saying that, you know, this is a global issue. He's the arbiter of the world. Exactly. Some people say, well, our borders, our obvious borders are geographical, the Pyrenees, the river Rhine, the channel, the Mediterranean, and so on.
革命会在哪里停下？因为当然他们一直认为这不仅是一个法国民族主义项目，而且是一个普世主义的项目。好吧，同样，这就是布里索所说的，（你知道的，这是一个全球性问题。）他是世界的仲裁者。绝对的。有些人说，好吧，我们的边界，我们明显的边界是地理上的，比利牛斯山脉、莱茵河、海峡、地中海等等。
But other people are saying, well, really? I mean, if we stand for liberty, if we stand for these kind of timeless, eternal values, why would we stop at some mountains? Why wouldn't we go beyond? And have they not enrolled as French citizens, people in foreign countries who are particularly enthusiastic for the revolutions? Like Tom Paine. Tom Paine would be the famous example.
但另一些人说，好吧，真的吗？我的意思是，如果我们代表自由，如果我们代表这些超越时间的永恒价值观，我们为什么要在一些山脉前停下？我们为什么不超越它们？他们难道没有把外国那些对革命特别热情的民众登记为法国公民吗？比如托马斯·潘恩。托马斯·潘恩就是一个著名的例子。
On the 19th of November, they vote. France will assist anybody, anybody who wants to, and I quote, recover their liberty. And a month later, they agree that everywhere French armies go, they will take the revolution with them. So that means they will abolish feudalism. They will attack the privileges of the Catholic Church. They will institute a Republican system. So it's a war on the monarchies of Europe.
在11月19日，他们投票决定。法国将协助任何人，任何想要——我引用——“恢复自由”的人。一个月后，他们一致同意，无论法国军队走到哪里，他们都将把革命带到那里。这意味着他们将废除封建制度。他们将攻击天主教会的特权。他们将建立一个共和体制。所以这是一场对欧洲君主国的战争。
So this has never happened before in European history. You know, states have fought wars with each other, of course, and taken each other's territory, but the idea that you would go into somebody's country and completely rewire their system so that it looks like yours, ideologically reboot them, this to a lot of people is profoundly, profoundly shocking. So Cromwell hadn't done that. No, I mean, there'd be no sense of let's export the English revolution.
所以这在欧洲历史上从未发生过。你知道的，国家之间当然打过仗，也夺取过彼此的领土，但那种你会进入别人的国家并彻底重新布线他们的系统，使其看起来像你的一样，在意识形态上重新启动他们的想法，这对许多人来说是极其极其震撼的。所以克伦威尔并没有这样做。不，我的意思是，当时根本没有出口英国革命的意识。
Exactly. And what is more, I mean, I think this is very French. They decide that they will make everybody else pay for this. So there's a guy called Pierre-Jacques Combo, who's a Protestant merchant from Nîmes and he says, listen, there's an obvious way to, to fund the, this when we occupy a given country, they should be so grateful for their Liberty that they should pay us a tax to pay for their own occupation. And the convention, this is a, this is an absolutely, absolutely great idea.
完全没有。而且更重要的是，我的意思是，我认为这非常法国化。他们决定让其他所有人都为此买单。所以有一个叫皮埃尔-雅克·康邦的人，他是尼姆的新教商人，他说，听着，有一个显而易见的方法来为这个提供资金，当我们占领一个特定的国家时，他们应该对他们的自由如此感激，以至于他们应该向我们交税来支付他们自己的占领费用。国民公会认为这绝对是个绝妙的主意。
Now you might think this sounds very over the top and hubristic, but they, I think, really believe in this. Briceau is standing there in the convention, November 1792, and he is saying, we will liberate Naples, we will liberate Spain, we will liberate Poland. We will be in Berlin probably this time next year. We can go all the way to Moscow. You know, it's like they're basically drunk on their own rhetoric. His friend Vernio, remember we had him talk about the, there's a great quote from him,
现在你可能会觉得这听起来太自大狂妄了，但我认为他们真的相信这一点。布里索站在国民公会里，1792年11月，他说，我们将解放那不勒斯，我们将解放西班牙，我们将解放波兰。明年这个时候我们可能就在柏林了。我们可以一路走到莫斯科。你知道的，这就像他们基本上被自己的修辞冲昏了头脑。他的朋友韦尼奥，还记得我们让他谈过，关于他有一句名言，
he's a great orator talking about the declaration of war in the first place. He now says, this will actually be the last war. This will be the end of history. Men have died, he says, but they have died so that no men will ever die again. I swear to you in the name of the universal fraternity which you are creating that each battle will be a step towards peace, humanity and happiness for all mankind. So I think if that's what they're bringing, it's fair enough to get people to pay for
他是一位伟大的演说家，最初在讨论宣战时发表了演讲。他现在说，这实际上将是最后一场战争。这将是历史的终结。他说，人们已经死去，但他们死去是为了让任何人再也不会死去。我以你们正在创造的普世兄弟情谊的名义向你们发誓，每一场战役都将是迈向和平、全人类幸福与人道的一步。所以我想，如果这就是他们带来的东西，让人们为此付钱也是理所应当的。
it. Very good. I mean, the thing is is nobody has ever talked like this in European history before, you know, when France was fighting its wars in Italy in the early 16th century, nobody said this is the war to end all wars. This will bring a new age of happiness. They just said, brilliant. Let's pile into Milan and Luton pillage. You know, did Henry the fifth say this in the hundred years war?
很好。我的意思是，问题在于欧洲历史上从来没有人这样说过，你知道的，当法国在16世纪初在意大利打仗时，没有人说过这是结束所有战争的战争。这将带来一个幸福的新时代。他们只是说，太棒了。让我们冲进米兰去掠夺。亨利五世在百年战争中说过这话吗？
Did Edward the third? Of course they didn't. But the dream of a universal peace is of course, I mean, you know, we know where that's coming from. We do indeed. But of course, there is, among other things, there's a very obvious problem that they have, which is, it's a problem left over from before the Republic. And it's that they have still in their midst,
爱德华三世说过吗？他们当然没有。但对普世和平的梦想当然是——我的意思是，我们知道那是从哪里来的。我们确实知道。但当然，除其他外，他们有一个非常明显的问题，那就是，这是一个从共和国建立之前遗留下来问题。那就是在他们当中依然存在着，
not just any old traitor, but the traitor of traitors, you know, a rallying point for counter revolution. So the erstwhile king. It is the erstwhile king, it's Louis Capet. Well, so that is what they call him, Louis Capet, because the man who is elected King of the Franks at the end of the 10th century is Hugh cap a so that's where the name of the Capetians comes from it's not actually his name and in the next episode where we look at the trial and execution of
不仅仅是随便什么旧叛徒，而是叛徒中的叛徒，你知道的，反革命的集结点。也就是昔日的国王。正是昔日的国王，路易·卡佩。好吧，所以这就是他们叫他的名字，路易·卡佩，因为在10世纪末被选为法兰克人国王的那个人是于格·卡佩，这就是卡佩王朝名字的由来，这其实不是他的姓氏，在下一集中，我们将探讨对国王的审判和处决，
the king we'll explore why they call him Louie cap and not Louie Bourbon but I just I just intrude with that but they they call him Louis Capet. That never occurred to me before. Obviously that isn't really his name. No, it's not his name and he and Louis object very strongly to being called Capet, but we will explore this tomorrow. That's tantalizing. Tom, if I wasn't already a member of the Restless History Club, I'd sign up now because I'd have to wait. So just the last five minutes or so before Theo explodes with rage
我们将探讨为什么他们叫他路易·卡佩而不是路易·波旁，但我只是——我只是插话提一下这个——但他们叫他路易·卡佩。这以前从未在我脑海中出现过。显然那真的不是他的名字。不，这不是他的名字，路易强烈反对被称为卡佩，但我们明天会探讨这一点。这太诱人了。汤姆，如果我还不是“不安分历史俱乐部”的成员，我现在就会报名，因为我不得不等待。所以在西奥因为我们讲得太久而勃然大怒之前的最后五分钟左右，路易这段时间一直都在哪里？他一直被关在圣殿塔这座中世纪城堡里。他和玛丽·安托瓦内特、他的妹妹伊丽莎白以及他的两个孩子在一起。他们一直在读大量的书，他们基本上过着像新冠疫情封锁期间的中产阶级英格兰家庭一样的生活。所以路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特一直在给孩子们在家上学。他们一直在教他们背诵海量的
that we're going on too long. Where has Louie been all this time? He's been in the temple in this medieval keep. He's been with Mary Antoinette, his sister Elizabeth and his two children. They'd been reading loads of books that they basically living like a middle class English family during COVID in lockdown. So Louie and Mary Antoinette have been homeschooling the children. They've been teaching them to recite kind of great
拉辛和高乃依等伟大法国剧作家的作品。路易热爱地理。所以他们一直在给法国新省份的地图涂色，描摹并做所有这些事情。其实挺温馨的。他们在花园里打羽毛球，到了晚上，路易——这会取悦到你的，汤姆——他会给他们朗读罗马历史的片段。但大概不是关于共和国建立的片段吧？不，我不这么认为。但显然他读的那些片段在某种程度上反映了他们自己的困境。
reams of Racine and Corneille and stuff, great French dramatists. Louis loves his geography. So they've been coloring in a map of the new departments of France and tracing and doing all this stuff. It's actually quite sweet. They play badminton in the garden and at night, Louis, this will please you Tom, he reads passages of Roman history to them. But presumably not the establishment of the Republic. No, I don't think so. But apparently he reads passages that somehow mirror their own predicament.
所以就是那些被关起来，但非常高贵、隐忍不拔之类的人。他们的限制非常严格。玛丽·安托瓦内特不允许缝纫，以防她在缝制密码。路易不允许刮胡子，因为人们意识到他可能会自杀。而卫兵们——这非常像1918年的罗曼诺夫王朝——卫兵们总是在墙上乱涂乱画，画着一个胖子被绞死或断头台处决之类的东西。所以这对路易来说有点不祥。现在，国民公会，你可能会说，他们为什么一定要对他进行任何诉讼呢？因为他现在只是个公民。这就是路易·卡佩的意义所在。他就像其他任何人一样。
So people who've been locked up, but are very noble and long suffering and all this kind of thing. They are quite tightly restricted. Marion Trenet's not allowed to sew in case she's sewing a code. Louis is not allowed to shave because people are aware that he might kill himself. And the guards, it's very like the Romanoffs in 1918, the guards were always kind of scribbling graffiti on the wall that shows a fat man being hanged or guillotined or something. So that's a bit ominous for Louis. Now the convention, you might say, why do they have to take any proceedings against him at all? Because he's just a citizen now. This is the point of Louis Capet. He's just like anyone else.
但有两个原因。第一，如果他们真的认为他一直在向外国敌人出卖他们，他们真的应该惩罚他。第二，他们知道法国有大量的保王党。他们不能留下这样一个明显的反革命叛乱的核心。巴黎街头的无套裤汉仍然指责他，记住，指责他在杜伊勒里宫的战斗、瑞士卫队以及所有这些事情。他们进行了激烈的讨论，关于从宪法上讲他们是否被允许对他进行审判，因为根据旧宪法，如果国王（你知道的）违背了它，宪法规定了你该怎么做，你将他撤职，但一旦你这么做了，事情就结束了——所以他们还能进一步惩罚他吗？基本上他们找了一个宪法律师，一个来自图卢兹名叫让-巴蒂斯特·梅的人，他说路易显然犯下了可怕的罪行，自然法凌驾于宪法之上。宪法实际上是由国家赋予的。
But there are two reasons. One is if they really think he's been betraying them to foreign enemies, they really ought to punish him. And number two, they know there are loads of royalists in France. They can't leave such an obvious focus for counter-revolutionary rebellion alive. And the son culotte on the streets of Paris still blame him, remember, for the fighting at the Tuileries and the Swiss Guards and all of that sort of business. They have a huge discussion about whether constitutionally they are allowed to put him on trial because under the old constitution if the king you know transgressed it laid down what you do and you remove him from office but once you do that it's done so can they punish him further and basically they get a constitutional lawyer, a guy from Toulouse called Jean Baptiste May, and he says Louis is clearly guilty of terrible crimes and the law of nature overrides the constitution. The constitution actually was given by the nation.
如果国家赋予了宪法，国家就有权撤回它，而自然法则要求惩罚路易。这难道不是未来一年将要发生的事情的历史中的一个关键时刻吗？这种观点认为，如果你遵循自然，那么你无论走到哪里都不会做错事。这再次非常卢梭，非常卢梭。所以他们就这该如何运作进行了某种辩论。少数人，一小群——我想你会说是国民公会右翼、吉伦特派右翼的人——说我只是认为我们应该放过他，别搞这一套了。但大多数人说我们可能应该进行审判。然而，有些山岳派说审判简直是疯了。
And if the nation gives the constitution, the nation has the right to withdraw it and the law of nature demands that Louis is punished. And this is a crucial moment isn't it in the history of what will happen over the next year. The idea that if you follow nature then you can't do anything wrong no matter where it leads. There again very Russo, very Russo. So they have a sort of debate about how this will work. A few people, a very small group of kind of what you I suppose you would say people on the right of the convention, on the right of the Girondin group say I just think we should leave him alone, let's not do this at all. But most people say we should probably have a trial. There are some Montagnards however who say a trial is mad.
我们应该直接杀了他。他甚至不配接受审判。其中最著名的一个人，一个我们现在应该介绍的角色，是一个年轻人，整个国民公会中最年轻的议员。他年仅25岁，在11月起立发表了他的首次演讲。所以这个人叫路易-安托万·圣茹斯特。他来自皮卡第的一个小镇。他基本上是罗伯斯庇尔的超级粉丝。他从1789年就开始给他写粉丝信了。我一直觉得圣茹斯特身上，这就是卢梭和浪漫主义交汇的点。他留着长长的油腻头发。他戴着耳环。他非常苍白。人们从没见他微笑或大笑过。
We should just kill him straight away. He doesn't even deserve a trial. And the most famous one of those, a character who we should now introduce, is a young man, the youngest deputy in the whole convention. He's only 25 years old and he stands up to make his maiden speech in November. So this guy is called Louis-Antoine Saint-Just. He's from a small town in Picardy. He's basically a massive Robespierre fan. He's been sending him fan mail since 1789. And I kind of think about Saint-Just that here's the point at which Rousseau and romanticism kind of meet. He's got long,ank hair. He's got an earring. He's very pale. He's never seen smiling or laughing.
他是拥有政治权力的雪莱。是的，我想他是。我想是的。是雪莱在伊顿公学被同学追赶吗？是的，猎杀雪莱。猎杀雪莱。是的。我本来很想在圣茹斯特身上看到这一点，因为我讨厌圣茹斯特。他写了一首很长的诗，不是吗，关于他的性挫折。不出所料。他确实写了。而且他引以为傲。
He's Shelley with political power. Yes, I guess he is. I guess. Was it Shelley who was pursued by his classmates around Eton? Yes, the Shelley hunt. The Shelley hunt. Yeah. That I would have loved to have seen that with Sanjeev because I hate Sanjeev. He wrote an enormous poem, didn't he, about his sexual frustration. Surprise, surprise. He did. And he prides himself.
他基本上爱慕罗伯斯庇尔，并以自己更加正直、更加没有感情、更加合乎逻辑而自豪。理性主义者。是的。比罗伯斯庇尔还要理性。这种理性主义和美德是可以划等号的。是的。同样，这也是某种东西的诞生，在19世纪的过程中，它实际上会变得相当令人不寒而栗。这就是陀思妥耶夫斯基所痴迷的那种东西。是的。
He basically loves Rob Spear and he prides himself on being more, even more virtuous, more emotionless, more logical. Rationalist. Yeah. Than Rob Spear. That rationalism and virtue are to be equated. Yes. And again, this is the birth of something that over the course of the 19th century will actually become quite chilling. It's the kind of thing Dostoevsky was obsessed by. Yeah.
圣茹斯特主义者是陀思妥耶夫斯基小说中恐怖分子的创始范例。他绝对是。同样，他喜欢这个概念，“恐怖”这个词本身就是一个非常圣茹斯特式的词，但他的理性主义，他那种冰冷的理性主义，是一个充满被压抑的情感的躯体中冰冷的理性主义。不是吗？我的意思是，基本上他是一个“无爱者（incel）”。他完全是。他是一个只需要去散散步、结识一些女孩、和丹东一起闲逛的男人。
The Saint-Juicest is the founding paradigm of the terrorists that you get in Dostoevsky's novels. He absolutely is. Again, he loves the idea, the very word terror is a very Sanjus word, but his rationalism, his kind of icy rationalism is the icy rationalism of somebody who is throbbing with suppressed emotion. Isn't he? I mean, basically he's an incel. He is a total. He is a man who just needs to go for a walk, meet some girls, hang out with Danton.
是的，没错。别带他去过好时光。无论如何，当然这种关系并没有以很好的方式结束，不是吗？所以圣茹斯特，也许并非巧合。所以圣茹斯特站起来说，嗯，根本不需要审判，因为他的观点是，路易并不是因为他做过的任何事而有罪。他有罪。这真正凸显了你的观点。
Yeah, exactly. Don't show him a good time. Anyway, of course that relationship doesn't end terribly well, does it? So I just, and don't perhaps not coincidentally. So Sanchez gets up and he says, um, there was no need for a trial because the point he says is that Louie's not guilty because of anything he's done. He's guilty. And this really brings out your point.
这绝对预示了19世纪和20世纪的大量革命性事物。圣茹斯特说，他有罪是因为他的身份以及他曾经是什么。一个美德的共和国不能容忍一个曾经是国王的人活下去。我引用：“没有人能无辜地统治。每一个国王都是叛逆者和篡位者。”所以没有中间地带。这个人必须统治或者死去。
This absolutely anticipates so much of the revolutionary stuff of the 19th and 20th centuries. Sanchez says he's guilty because of what he is and what he has been. A virtuous Republic cannot allow somebody who has been a King to live. And I quote, no one can reign innocently. Every King is a rebel under usurper. So there's no middle ground. This man must reign or die.
为了保证人民的安宁，他必须死。对的。多米尼克，那是——那是至关重要的、打开对国王审判和处决正确理解的台词，因为共和国没有一个奠基的时刻。没有宣言。那是因为国王依然活着。因此，国王的死变成了共和国的某种洗礼。我认为这就是为什么圣茹斯特的演讲如此令人难忘和意义重大。是的，我认为这是一个非常好的观点，汤姆。这是一个非常——因为它确实是整个革命中最著名两三次演讲之一。它让圣茹斯特名声大噪，并且正如你所说，它似乎成为了法国宪政之旅中的一个起点、一个标点符号。无论如何，关于这个演讲有趣的事情是，它实际上并没有起作用，因为他们决定进行审判。所以当他们为审判做计划时，就在我们进入那个环节之前，就在他们敲定审判计划时，有一个非常非常重要的进展。罗兰先生，罗兰夫人的丈夫，作为吉伦特派的内政部长，在11月20日被一个名叫加马尔的锁匠带进了杜伊勒里宫。
He must die to assure the repose of the people. Right. And Dominic, that is, that is the crucial, crucial line that opens up, I think, the proper understanding of the trial and execution of the king, because there is no foundational moment for the republic. There is no proclamation. And that is because the king still lives. So therefore, the death of the king becomes the kind of the baptism of the Republic. And I think that that is why Saint-Juic's speech is so memorable and so significant. Yeah, I think that's a really good point, Tom. It's a very, because it does, it is one
他必须死，以确保人民的安宁。没错。多米尼克，那是、那是至关重要的一行话，我认为它开启了对国王审判和处决的正确理解，因为共和国没有奠基时刻。没有宣言。那是因为国王依然活着。因此，国王之死成了共和国的一种洗礼。我认为这就是圣茹斯特的演讲如此令人难忘且意义重大的原因。是的，汤姆，我觉得这是一个非常好的观点。这是一个非常……因为它确实是其中之一
of the two or three most famous speeches of the entire revolution. It makes Saint-Juic's name and it also, as you say, seems to serve as a kind of departure point, as a punctuation point in kind of France's constitutional journey. Anyway, the funny thing about this speech is actually it doesn't work because they decide they will have a trial. So while they're making the plans for the trial, just before we get into that, just as they're finalizing the plans for the trial, there is a really, really important development. Monsieur Rolland, the husband of Madame Rolland, the interior minister who's a gérondeur, on the 20th of November is taken into the Tuileries Palace by a locksmith called Gamart.
整场革命中最著名两三次演讲之一。它让圣茹斯特名声大噪，正如你所说，它似乎也成了法国立宪历程中的一个出发点、一个标点符号。总之，关于这篇演讲有趣的是，它其实并没有起作用，因为他们决定进行审判。因此，当他们在筹划审判时——在我们进入正题之前，就在他们敲定审判计划之际——发生了一个非常非常重要的进展。11月20日，吉伦特派内政部长罗兰夫人（Madame Rolland）的丈夫罗兰先生（Monsieur Rolland），被一个名叫加马尔（Gamart）的锁匠带进了杜伊勒里宫。
Gamart was the guy who had taught the king all about his locks. And Gamart says to Monsieur Roland, no one knows this, but I'm going to show you something. And he takes him and he shows him a secret iron safe hidden behind the paneling. Roland opens it and it's full of confidential papers and documents. And he now makes a terrible mistake, a mistake that I think will kill him. He takes the papers out and he goes through them himself in secret. He doesn't share them with anybody. And then he goes to the convention.
加马尔是那个教给国王所有关于他锁具知识的人。加马尔对罗兰先生说，没人知道这件事，但我今天要给你看样东西。然后他带着罗兰去看藏在护墙板后面一个秘密的铁保险箱。罗兰打开一看，里面全是机密文件和档案。他现在犯了一个可怕的错误，一个我认为会要了他命的错误。他把文件拿出来，自作主张地私下查阅起来。他没有跟任何人分享。然后他去了国民公会。
He says, well, I've made an amazing discovery. I have found all these confidential documents and they, I can let me tell you, there's some pretty interesting things in them that will incriminate some of you. And you will, you won't be laughing then. And lots of deputies are really shocked and frightened and outraged at this, especially the Montagnard. They're like, what are these documents? How do we know that you haven't, you know, forged them?
他说，嗯，我有一个惊人的发现。我找到了所有这些机密文件，我得告诉你们，里面有一些相当有趣的东西，会牵连你们中的一些人。到那时候你们就笑不出来了。许多议员对此感到极其震惊、害怕和愤怒，尤其是山岳派。他们质问：这些文件是什么？我们怎么知道是不是你们伪造的呢？
Exactly. They're, they're absolutely furious. So all this will come back to really haunt Roland and the Gironne down. But in the meantime, the documents prove two things. First of all, they prove now beyond any possible doubt that Louis was conspiring against the revolution. He was in touch with the Austrians. He was writing to counter revolutionary groups.
没错。他们简直怒不可遏。所以这一切最终都会报应在罗兰和吉伦特派身上。但与此同时，这些文件证明了两件事。首先，它们现在无可辩驳地证明了路易确实在阴谋对抗革命。他与奥地利人保持联系，他写信给反革命集团。
He was doing all of this kind of stuff. Yeah. Cause his signatures are all over these papers. His fate is sealed from this point that he has done. I think the second thing they, the documents also proved beyond any possible doubt that all that stuff about the mask of patriotism, which we've discussed as though it's so paranoid and such a mad conspiracy theory. It's indeed quite accurate because one of the great heroes of the early
他一直在搞这些勾当。是的，因为这些文件到处都是他的签名。从这一刻起，他的命运已经注定，他做过的事……我认为第二点，这些文件也无可辩驳地证明了我们之前讨论过的关于“爱国主义面具”的种种说法，虽然听起来像是被迫害妄想和疯狂的阴谋论，但事实上却相当准确。因为早期革命的伟大英雄之一
revolution, Mirabeau, another man with terrible skin, by the way, he's clearly, there's loads of letters from him showing that he was conspiring against the revolution, taking loads of money from the courts and you know his his reputation is shredded they go and take his ashes out of the pantheon they take his bust out of the Jacquemin Club they're like well this proves the point can't trust anyone can't trust anybody so few days after this the 1st of December the convention votes first of all anyone who calls for the return of the monarchy anyone who who makes who makes any, and I quote, infringement on the sovereignty of the people, which is very satisfyingly vague.
米拉波——顺便说一句，这也是个皮肤很糟糕的人——有大量信件清楚地显示他在阴谋反对革命，从宫廷拿了大量的钱，你知道的，他的声誉已经扫地了。他们去把他的骨灰从先贤祠里移走，把他的半身像从雅各宾俱乐部拿下来。他们觉得，这证明了一点：谁也不能相信，谁都不能相信。所以在几天后的12月1日，国民公会首先投票通过了：任何呼吁恢复君主制的人，任何制造……我引述一下，“侵犯人民主权”的人——这个说法非常令人满意地模糊。
If you are, if you're a big fan of revolutionary terror, will face punishment by death and two days later, they vote that this man, Louis Capet, we can discuss his name next time, will be brought before the National Convention to answer for his crimes. And Rob Spear gets up at the tribunal and he says, remember, your task is not to pass a sentence for and against a man. It is to defend the safety of the public and to take an act of national providence. I pronounce this fatal truth with regret, but Louis must die because the homeland must live.
如果你是革命恐怖的超级粉丝，将面临死刑的惩罚。两天后，他们投票决定这个人——路易·卡佩（我们下次可以讨论他的名字）——将被带到国民公会前为他的罪行接受审判。罗伯斯庇尔在法庭上站起来说：记住，你们的任务不是对一个人做出有罪或无罪的判决，而是捍卫公众的安全，进行一场国民天意的行动。我怀着遗憾的心态说出这个致命的真理，但路易必须死，因为祖国必须生。
Amazing stuff. So Dominic and everyone, the scene is set. Louis will be brought to trial. Will he be convicted? If he is convicted, what will his fate be? There is only one way to find out and that is to tune into the next episode. If you simply can't wait, then you can go to the rest of this history.com and sign up there. But either way, we are approaching the climax of this particular stage of our series on the French Revolution. So we'll see you very soon. Bye bye. Au revoir. Now, Tom, as you know, I am not just a man of history. I'm also known for my involvement in the performing arts.
太精彩了。所以，多米尼克和各位，舞台已经搭好。路易将被送上法庭。他会被定罪吗？如果他被定罪，他的命运会是什么？只有一个方法可以找到答案，那就是收听下一集。如果你实在等不及，可以访问 restofthishistory.com 在那里注册。但无论如何，我们正在接近法国大革命系列这一特定阶段的高潮。所以我们很快再见。再见。Au revoir。好了，汤姆，如你所知，我不只是个历史人，我也因参与表演艺术而闻名。
Are you now? I must confess that early on in my acting career, my stage presence did come under a little scrutiny from Britain's finest newspapers. Oh yes, this is the famous, notorious one-star review in the Scotsmanism. Yeah, and I will remind the listeners that in Scotland they order their reviews in a different way, so one is at the top and five stars is the worst review you could get, so we were very happy with that one-star review. But like a lot of great masters of their craft, Tom, I learned from it. I grew. I evolved. I knew I would bide my time before returning to the boards. And guess what? You're not. No. Yes. Tom, I have to tell you, I have returned to the boards. I'm performing once again. And the
是吗？我必须承认，在我的演艺生涯早期，我的舞台表现确实受到过英国几家最好报纸的严厉审视。哦对，这就是苏格兰人报上那篇著名的、臭名昭著的一星评价。是的，我要提醒听众们，在苏格兰他们的评分方式不一样，一星是最好的，五星是最差的评价，所以我们对那个一星评价非常满意。但就像许多技艺高超的大师一样，汤姆，我从中吸取了教训。我成长了。我进化了。我知道我应该养精蓄锐，然后再重返舞台。你猜怎么着？你没有。不。是的。汤姆，我必须告诉你，我重返舞台了。我又开始演出了，而且……
brilliant news for our listeners is that you can go and you can be transfixed by my performance right now because I am honoured and privileged to appear in the latest Sherlock and co adventure the adventure of the Norwood builder please tell me that you are playing for Norwood builder I'm playing a much better character I'm playing Hector McFarlane a solicitor from Blackheath accused of murder goodness as Lestrade's officers bear down on me, Tom, I have nowhere else to turn but to 22-1B Baker Street. This is amazing, Dominic. And the fact that you were cast in this role, it has nothing to do with the fact that Sherlock and Co. is a goal-hanger production like this one. Well, very much like this one with a better acting, I think it's fair to say. It's a stablemate of
对于我们的听众来说，一个绝妙的好消息是，你现在就可以去欣赏我的表演，为之神魂颠倒，因为我很荣幸、很特权地出现在最新的《福尔摩斯和合伙人》冒险故事《诺伍德的建筑师》中。请告诉我你演的不是诺伍德的建筑师。我演的是一个好得多的角色，我演的是赫克托·麦克法兰，一个来自布莱克希斯的律师，被控谋杀。天哪，当雷斯特莱德的警官们向我逼近时，汤姆，我除了221B贝克街无路可走。这太棒了，多米尼克。你被选中扮演这个角色，这绝对跟《福尔摩斯和合伙人》和我们节目一样是个挂钩制作毫无关系。哦，非常像这个节目，只不过演技更好，我觉得这么说挺公平的。它是我们的……
ours. They are a massive show. They get 10 million downloads outside, I believe, the Archers. This is the biggest audio drama in Britain. Well, I have no doubt Dominic that it is more interesting than the Archers. It genuinely is brilliant. So my son is a massive Sherlock and co-officionado. It basically goes through all the original short stories and the short stories that are often forgotten in modern day adaptations. It transposes Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's narratives to the modern day. So Watson himself is making the podcast while they're doing the adventures. You can pick up any adventure you want. You don't have to follow the whole series to get stuck in. It is absolutely brilliant. And
同门兄弟。它们是一个巨大的节目。除了《弓箭手》之外，它们有1000万的下载量，我相信。这是英国最大的广播剧。嗯，多米尼克，毫无疑问它比《弓箭手》更有趣。它确实非常精彩。所以我的儿子是《福尔摩斯和合伙人》的超级粉丝。它基本上把所有的原创短篇小说都过了一遍，包括那些在现代改编中常常被遗忘的短篇小说。它将柯南·道尔爵士的故事搬到了现代。所以华生自己一边经历冒险一边在做播客。你可以挑选任何你想听的冒险故事。你不需要听完整整个系列就能入坑。它绝对太棒了，而且……
do you know who else thinks it's brilliant, Tom? The Guardian newspaper. One of those prized one-star reviews. No, a five-star. They said, and I quote, very funny, mildly sweary and hugely popular. Do you want to know what the Times said? It said, a breakneck series that Gen Z, or Gen Z as members of it say, that Gen Z is hooked on. Wow. And now that you're appearing on the show, I mean that will confirm the hook, won't it? It absolutely will, and the Guardian listeners will be beside themselves with joy. So, everybody, please listen to Sherlock and Co. The Adventure of the Norwood Builder.
你知道还有谁觉得它棒吗，汤姆？《卫报》。就是那些宝贵的一星评价之一。不，是五星。他们说，引述一下：“非常搞笑，带点微小的粗口，而且极其受欢迎。”你想知道《泰晤士报》是怎么说的吗？它说：“一部让Z世代——或者像Z世代成员自己说的那样，Gen Z——欲罢不能的疾速系列。”哇。既然你现在也出现在节目里，我的意思是这更加实锤了这种欲罢不能，对吧？绝对是的，卫报的听众们一定会高兴得合不拢嘴。所以，各位，请收听《福尔摩斯和合伙人》之《诺伍德的建筑师》。
It's multi-part, it's brilliant, part one is out now. Jump right in wherever you get your podcasts. And here is a clip from that very episode. He was murdered. Supposedly. Nobody has been found yet, Watson. Yeah, but... Now listen, you said you would hear me out, didn't you? Do you want to just dial it down a bit, Hector? Would you?
它是多集的，非常精彩，第一部分现在已经上线。无论你在哪里收听播客，随时都可以直接跳进去。这里是那一集的精彩片段。他被谋杀了。据说是这样。还没找到尸体呢，华生。是啊，但是……听着，你答应过听我把话说完的，不是吗？你就不能稍微冷静点吗，赫克托？行吗？
Would you dial it down when you're smeared over every paper? Look at this! Look at this! In the Times, here, look. Solicitor suspected for contractor disappearance. The Telegraph. Solicitor faces long arm of law. The Daily Mail. Bully of Blackheath.
当各大报纸都把你抹黑的时候，你能冷静下来吗？看这个！看这个！泰晤士报，这里，看。律师涉嫌承包商失踪案。每日电讯报。律师难逃法网。每日邮报。布莱克希斯的恶霸。
Elite London lawyer facing murder charge. And this is just, this is, this is, The Guardian, here look at this. Old Acre Murder. How neoliberal materialism and cursty all sort of home renovations are the real killers of the working. Oh well that one goes on a bit.
伦敦精英律师面临谋杀指控。还有这个，这个，这个，《卫报》，这里看这个。老橡树谋杀案。新自由主义物质主义和暴风雨般的家居装修如何成为工人的真正杀手。哦，好吧，那个有点没完没了。
Yeah, we get the point. Do you? Do you? I'm not sure you do. The Daily Sports. Big Job Love. McFarlane's wife's steamy romp with missing builder. I mean look, there's a thought bubble above my wife's head saying, knob the builder, can he fix it?
对，我们懂那个意思。是吗？你懂吗？我可不觉得你懂。《每日体育报》。大工程的爱。麦克法兰的妻子与失踪建筑商的激情偷情。我的意思是，看，我妻子头上有个思考气泡写着：跟建筑商搞上了，他能搞定吗？
Hector. The speech bubble I of his mouth. Here's your extension, love. I mean, this is just... The son. Cannibal Hector. McFarlane confesses to eating Norwood Tradesman. You confess to what? Sorry.
赫克托。他嘴里的对话气泡。这是你的扩建工程，亲爱的。我的意思是，这简直……《太阳报》。食人族赫克托·麦克法兰承认吃掉了诺伍德商人。你承认了什么？对不起。
I didn't confess to a damn thing! I said I was hungry for justice! That's all! It is slander! It's disgraceful, it's bloody humiliating. Could we perhaps return to the chain of events as you, not the press, perceive them? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我什么鬼都没承认！我说我渴望正义！就这样！这是诽谤！这太无耻了，简直血淋淋的羞辱。我们能不能回到你——而不是媒体——所理解的事态发展上来？本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。